Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Wir sehen uns in der nächsten Folge. Der Sound ist klar, wenn man den hört, weiß man ganz genau, es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat und wieder Zeit fürs Chaosradio. Finde den Fehler. Es ist ab jetzt nicht mehr der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, sondern der letzte Donnerstag im Monat, in dem das Chaosradio immer stattfindet, aber dort wird es weiterhin und wie gewohnt stattfinden. Heute zu Gast im Chaosradio, also der Radiosendung des Chaos Computer Clubs, wo folgerichtig Leute vom Chaos Computer Club oder beziehungsweise befreundeten Institutionen zu Gast sind. Nibbler vom CCC, tach.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Und Alex von den Freifunkern. Das ist aber ganz schön leise und irgendwie funktioniert das gar nicht. Nehmen wir das hier. Ah, sehr schön. So, wenn man die Webseite heute tagsüber beobachtet hat vom Chaosradio, das den Namen ja deshalb trägt, weil die Vorbereitungen auch immer etwas chaotisch sind, hat man gelesen können, es ginge um Eristik. Das ist jetzt zwar nicht mehr ganz der Fall, ich würde trotzdem gerne wissen, was ist das eigentlich.
Ja, so ein Thema für ein Chaosradio, wenn man schon ganz viele Themen bearbeitet hat zu finden und uns fiel auf, dass wir das Chaos in Chaosradio noch gar nicht dran hatten. Naja, gute Folge 23 ist auf jeden Fall in der Stelle nochmal eine gute Empfehlung. Das gibt einen auch einen gewissen Einblick in das Chaos, was uns da heute entgangen ist.
Okay, die Sendung, die ihr jetzt gerade nicht hört, die könnt ihr hören, wenn ihr euch das Chaosradio 23 rausholt. Sehr schön, okay.
Ja, also die Theorie ist halt, dass es da mal Chaos und Ordnung gibt und dass es Bestrebungen gibt in diese Welt und alles, was hier zusammenhält, Ordnung zu bringen. Und die Theorie, dass da auch Chaos nicht schlecht tut. Und uns wär es da halt in der Sendung um das Chaos gegangen. Aber das können wir vielleicht einen anderen Mal für alle.
So ein bisschen Chaos ist halt mal drin. Okay, heute dann aber nicht Chaos in der Sendung oder nur ein bisschen zumindest. Es geht heute um was ganz anderes, nämlich um Freifunk. Mich persönlich freut das, weil Freifunk ist ein Thema, das ich schon oft so am Wickel hatte. So ein bisschen nebenbei, so kurz hier, die haben wieder was gemacht. Was ist denn das? Erklärt mal kurz. Ach, irgendwie Netz. Und das klären wir heute ganz genau und zwei Stunden lang. Alex, du bist von den Freifunkern. Und ja, Freifunk, was ist das eigentlich?
Ja, das ist eine der großen Fragen der Bewegung. Wie definiert sich Freifunk und was ist es eigentlich? Und eine der Aussagen ist eigentlich, jeder versteht unter Freifunk was anderes. Für die einen ist es eine große Bewegung, für die nächsten ist es ein digitaler Modelleisenbahnclub über den Dächern Berlins. Aber grundsätzlich geht es dabei um freie Informationsinfrastruktur.
Okay, jetzt nochmal so für alle, die noch nicht wissen, was das ist. Das ist schon okay, aber ich glaube selbst, wenn man sich mit Rechnern so auskennt, wenn man jetzt noch nicht wüsste, was Freifunk genau ist, könnte man mit Modelleisenbahn über den Dächern auch nicht so viel anfangen.
Ja, also technisch gesehen ist es ein Funknetzwerk über den Dächern von Städten. Das gibt es in Berlin, Leipzig, Weimar. Das gibt es in Dörfern in Brandenburg. Das gibt es in Hamburg. Das basiert auf der WLAN Technologie, ist natürlich alles stark modifiziert. Auf die Art und Weise können Menschen miteinander kommunizieren und ins Internet gehen. Die Infrastruktur ist von den Teilnehmern selbst gebaut. Sie basiert auf Open Source, auf Linux und freier Software. Darauf, dass man Hardware anpasst. Natürlich Antennen und Funk und Gabeln und so weiter. Und ganz, ganz, ganz viele Menschen, die da zusammenarbeiten. Und ist ein freies Funknetz bzw. viele freie Funknetze.
Also sozusagen ist es nicht das normale Internet, so wie wir es kennen, sondern es ist ein extra gebasteltes Funknetz, wo sich die Freifunker zusammenschließen. Aber an irgendeiner Stelle müssen wir doch wieder ins richtige Internet.
Wo passiert das?
Das passiert an den sogenannten Uplinks. Das sind die Verbindungen ins GBI, ins große, böse Internet. Und das hatten wir auch schon in einer Sendung vor ein paar Wochen oder Monaten, wo es um dieses BGH-Urteil geht. Und die Rechtsfragen, das werden wir heute bestimmt auch nochmal ansprechen. Das sind halt die Leute, die sagen, hey, ich hab so viel Internet, ich kann davon was abgeben und ich geb das gleich meiner ganzen Nachbarschaft ab. Und dieses Freifunknetz, wie das funktioniert, können wir dann auch nochmal ansprechen. Sorgt dafür, dass du immer den nächstgelegenen Uplink hast. Das ist dann ein DSL-Anschluss, das kann auch ein Kabel Deutschland sein, das kann auch eine Glasfaser sein. Gibt es auch, also das ist eine Verbindung ins Internet und dieses Netz sorgt dann dafür, dass du, wenn du kein Internet hast, doch Internet hast.
Wir haben also so eine Art Hippienetzwerk, das heißt viele Leute schließen sich zusammen und alle geben das Internet, das sie haben, rein und dann teilen das alle miteinander. Genau. Wie das passiert, was man machen muss, um da zu kommen und mitzumachen, das kennen wir heute alles noch, aber ihr habt auch im Rahmen eures Bildungsauftrages hier im Chaosradio ein bisschen vorbereitet, wo das eigentlich herkommt. Das finde ich auch ganz spannend, weil ich dachte ja eher so, also okay, Freifunk, das kommt so vor, keine Ahnung, fünf oder sechs Jahren, hat jemand gedacht, ah zu wenig Internet, ah in Friedrichshain gibt es kein ordentliches DSL, da liegt nur Glasfaser, oh in Brandenburg gibt es auch noch kein DSL, wir machen jetzt einfach mal was. Aber die Idee ist schon viel älter. Sie kommt irgendwie aus den 80ern, habe ich euch schon sagen hören.
Oder noch früher. Um sich so die Idee dieses Freifunk vor Augen zu führen, muss man glaube ich ein bisschen in der Geschichte zurückgehen, als das mit dem Internet noch nicht so verbreitet war, wo man eben nicht irgendwie sagen konnte, ich hätte jetzt gerne das hier Internet auf diesen zwei Kupfer, also auf dieser Telefonleitung, die da ins Haus kommt, sondern das halt noch ein bisschen schwieriger war mit dem ordentlichen Internetzugang.
Ja, das Internet.
Oder überhaupt dem Datenaustauschen über Netze.
Das war ja auf alles verboten.
Gehen wir jetzt so Steinzeit zurück, also die ersten Freifunker gab es damals, als die Buschtrommeln brüderlich geteilt wurden, oder doch nicht ganz so weit?
Buschtrommeln, ja, so was Ähnliches. Also es war ja ganz furchtbar. Ich hab das noch ein bisschen mitgekriegt am Rande, als ich noch sehr jung war. Da gab es ja keine Telekom, da gab es die Post permanent, ohne sinnvolle Tätigkeit. Und die hatte halt auch dieses Fernmeldemonopol. Es gab ja auch keine Telefone, es gab Fernsprechapparate und es gab ein amtliches Fernsprechteilnehmerverzeichnis statt Telefonbuch. Und in der Zeit war es quasi unmöglich, für einen jungen Menschen Daten zu übertragen. Man konnte dann irgendwie an einen Modem rankommen oder einen Akustikkoppler. Und das war in den meisten Fällen auch noch verboten.
Da gab es auch dieses Datenklo, also ein Selbstbausatz, um sich einen Akustikkoppler, das ist ein Gerät, mit dem man Daten übertragen konnte über Telefone. Das sah so aus, dass man da zwei, und da hat es auch den Namen her, das Datenklo, zwei Pümpel-Aufsätze, also Pümpel, diese...
So Klo-Dinger?
So Klo-Dinger. Ich hab mal den Artikel, der ist lesenswert. Da erfährt man nicht nur, dass es ein Ding, mit dem man hinter Komik ist, sondern auch ein Saughector wird, das glaube ich in Österreich.
Das nur am Rande.
Das nur am Rande, ja. Es war eben so ein Gerät, wo man mit so zwei Saugpümpeln sich an das Telefonhörerchen ranklemmen konnte und dann vermittels Geräuschen Daten übertragen konnte.
Hat das nicht jetzt neulich jemand nachgebaut? Ja, ich glaube... Dieses ganz alte Datenklo?
Ich glaube Dexter hat damit mal...
Also, hab ich irgendwo im Netz gesehen. Wenn du ein Datenklo mal nachbauen wolltest, könnt ihr das jetzt wieder machen. Irgendjemand hat sich angeguckt, wie das geht und hat das gemacht. Damit ist man ins Netz gekommen, aber das ist ja dann wieder nur der einzelne Computer ins Netz. Wie hängt das Datenklo mit dem Freifunk zusammen? Ich mag diese Sendung jetzt schon. Wie hängt das Datenklo mit dem Freifunk zusammen?
Ja, es geht ja darum zu kommunizieren und dass das nicht möglich war aufgrund von Technik, von Geld, von Regulatorien. Und auch damals waren Leute kreativ und haben sich gesagt, irgendwie müssen wir das hinkriegen. Und mir wurde erzählt, dass sie damals Datasetten über CB-Funk überspielt haben als Beispiel.
CB-Funk muss man sagen ist, oh Gott, was ist das denn? Das ist auch schon ein bisschen älter, oder? Gibt es das noch?
Ich glaube, das gibt es schon.
Das macht man sich ja glatt alt, wenn man erklären darf, was ja.
Also CB-Funk ist total ganz normale Funkgeräte, die analog funken.
Ja, also so reinquatschen und auf der anderen Seite Quatschzeit raus.
Und die haben quasi die Datasetten, also Kassetten, auf denen Daten gespeichert waren, abgespielt und über den Funk verbreitet. Das war quasi das erste Freifunknetz, könnte man sagen?
Ja, könnte man sagen. Das war wahrscheinlich die erste freie Übertragung von Daten ohne große Technik. Einfach Kassettenrekorder ran, anschließen, hochdrehen. Das ist angeblich sogar am Ende lesbar gewesen.
Das ist ja das Problem früher gewesen, dass man eben für Speichermedien unglaublich viel Geld ausgeben musste für das Kettenstationen. Das war ja fragile, aufwändige Technik. Die günstige Variante davon war eben die Datasette, wo ganz einfach auf normale Magnettonkassetten, was man früher genutzt hat, um auch Musik aufzuzeichnen, da konnte man dann mit einem speziellen Wandler Daten aufzeichnen. Das hat sich dann wie ein Rauschen angehört. Und das war ein relativ verschwingliches Gerät, um eben aus Daten Ton zu machen. Und den kann man natürlich dann über besagte CB-Funkgeräte übertragen. Wiegt ja quasi nahe, wenn man so als Hacker zuhause sitzt und in seine Schublade guckt, was man alles rumliegen hat. Datasette, Funkgerät.
Das unterscheidet sich vom normalen Internetanspruch noch dadurch, dass man das nur gemacht hat, wenn man wirklich gerade Daten übertragen will. Also quasi Funkgerät ein, Datasette ein, Daten übertragen, alles wieder aus.
Das Internet früher gab es ja auch gar nicht. Da gab es zwar das Telefonnetz. Und über das Telefonnetz hat man dann auch später Internetzugang. Aber er hat auch generell Daten ausgetauscht. Und ich finde das so absurd, dass man früher über das Telefon Internet gemacht hat. Und heute macht man Telefon...
Also früher haben wir über die Telefonleitung Internet gemacht. Heute machen wir über die Internetleitung Telefon.
Richtig? Genau.
Kann man, also kurzer Anruf über Freifunk, kann man auch telefonieren dann?
Ja, ich mach das. Das funktioniert sogar manchmal. Ja, das ist erlaubt.
Ah, das funktioniert nicht mehr. Okay. Aber lass uns doch mal zurückkommen zu dem, also CB-Funk sozusagen sind die Anfänge. Wie ist denn jetzt das eigentliche mit, also wir verteilen Internetanschluss an Leute, die es eigentlich nicht haben. Wann hat das angefangen?
Oh, okay, ein großer Schwung.
Wie hat das angefangen?
Wäre ja jetzt noch ein bisschen der Vergangenheit geblieben.
Ach so, das ist ja generell die Frage.
Wie verteilt man Internet? Also wie kommt man, also in den Zeiten, wo man eben Internet über Telefon noch gemacht hat, wie kommt man überhaupt an dieses Internet ran?
Und ich hab damals irgendwie einen Kumpel im Chaos gehabt, der hatte halt Internet, der hatte dann ISDN und da konnte ich mich einwählen und ein bisschen Internet machen. Das war alles sehr begrenzt. Aber es gab da irgendwie damals noch Vau, Gott hat ihn selig, der damals schon von Bürgerdaten...
Okay, komm, also das hat er jetzt aber verdient, dass ein bisschen ausführlicher Vau wär?
Vau Holland, Ehrenmitglied und Gründer und Vaterfigur und whatever, der halt unter anderem auch über diese Bürgerdatenetze gesprochen hat.
Und der den CCC mit gegründet hat.
Ja, so was wie der Heilige.
Ja, heilig wollte ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber er hat schon gewisse Akzente gesetzt und Themen aufgebracht, angesprochen und nachgedacht und philosophiert, wie das eben mit diesen Computern und der Gesellschaft so aussieht und wohin die Reise geht und welche Fragen man sich da stellen muss. Und schon so ein bisschen den Grundstock gelegt für das, was den Club so in der Identität ausmacht und die Fragen, die wir uns da mit denen beschäftigen.
Also, wenn wir heute über Open Government reden, dann hieß das damals die Maschinenlesbare Regierung. Sehr viele Sachen damals schon angesprochen, die damals keiner verstanden hat. Und heute macht das jeder. Und Freifunk ist halt auch so ein Ding. Brauch hatte damals über Bürgerdatennetze gesprochen. Und was man dazu sagen muss, ist die Amateurfunka oder die Funkamateure, wie sie lieber genannt werden, die konnten damals schon Daten übertragen. Das war sehr langsam. Ich glaube, das war noch langsamer als unsere Telefonleitungen. Aber die konnten international funken. Die haben dann Packet Radio gemacht, so hieß das. Das Protokoll dazu AX25. Und konnten sich Mails zuschicken und konnten sich Daten zuschicken. Und was WAU damals auch in unzähligen Ausschüssen mit durchgebracht hat, ist, dass man diese Datenübertragungstechnik auch im CB-Funk verwenden darf. Und da gab es halt eine große Liberalisierung. Und jeder durfte. Und dann fing das Ganze natürlich an, dass es, WAU erklärte mir das mal, dass man halt sein eigenes Modem nicht anschließen darf. War alles verboten, musste von der Post sein. Und dass sie dann festgestellt haben, ja, was ein Modem ist und wie man das anschließt und warum nicht, ist eine Verordnung. Aber dafür kann man bestraft werden. Strafen dürfen aber nur aufgrund von Gesetzen und nicht aufgrund von Verordnungen in der Form sein. Sonst wären es Ordnungswidrigkeiten. Und damit haben sie den Hebel und Knackpunkt gefunden, um dieses Telefonnetz soweit aufzubrechen, auf juristischer Ebene, dass man dann tatsächlich eigene Endgeräte anschließen kann.
Sie haben nicht die Technik dafür gebastelt, sondern sie haben die, sie sagen, sie mussten die Gesetze soweit verbiegen, dass man das machen darf.
Das nimmt man, glaube ich, ein Stück weit, die noch interessant.
Da war es wieder.
Das Chaos.
Okay, also sie haben rechtlich geklärt.
Die normative Kraft des Faktischen.
Die normative Kraft, das hast du schön gesagt.
Und damit sind wir eigentlich schon wieder bei Freifunk. Wir können jetzt einfach mal 15 Jahre wegstreichen Geschichte, sonst sind wir mit der Geschichte fertig, wenn die Sendung zu Ende ist.
Kann man die irgendwo nachlesen? Oder muss man sie jetzt müde zusammenstückelen?
Also zusammenstückelen und Erferkreise besuchen und das Freifunk besuchen und sich von alten Leuten Geschichten erzählen, hilft da enorm.
Alles klar.
Der Rest steht im Internet.
15 Jahre später?
15 Jahre später waren wir in einer Welt in Deutschland, in der man technisch gesehen Daten grundstücksübergreifend transportieren kann. Dafür gab es diese WLAN-Technik und diese Funknetze, das war alles noch relativ teuer. Aber man durfte nicht. Und man musste dafür eine Lizenz haben, und man musste alles Mögliche tun, und es war sehr teuer. Und die EU sagte, hier ist eine Richtlinie, und die besagt, dass man das tun darf. Und naja, wie wir wissen, die Telekom und die Konzerne und Deutschland, die Regierung anyway, also die übliche gesellschaftskritische Nummer, haben das natürlich nicht umgesetzt.
Das sollten wir vielleicht in Zukunft aufnehmen. Bitte fügen sie an dieser Stelle die übliche gesellschaftskritische Nummer ein.
Und nach zwei Jahren wurde es dinggültig, und das war dann der Startschuss für das legale Freifunken, weil von dem Moment an war es quasi nur noch meldepflichtig.
Ab diesem Zeitpunkt durfte jeder, der wollte Daten versenden, also verfunken?
Grundstücksübergreifend.
Grundstücksübergreifend, okay.
Man muss sich das mal so vorstellen, da gab es dann Unis, die wollten ein Gebäude anbinden, und die Post hat ihnen natürlich nicht das Ethernetkabel über die Straße gelegt, daraufhin musste die Stadt der Uni einen Meter Straße verkaufen, und die Uni das an die Stadt zurückverpachten, damit es keine grundstücksübergreifende Kommunikation ist, und dann durfte die Uni dort ein Kabel einbauen. Das ist damit dann alles gefallen. Und damit durften wir dann zugeben, dass wir freifunken.
Das ist natürlich schon viel länger passiert, aber seitdem durfte man das offiziell.
Ja. Das ist so das Geschichtliche. Und dann gab es eine Treffen, ich glaube in London waren das, da gab es die consium.net Leute, die dort Access Points aufgestellt haben, ohne Verschlüsselung, gesagt jeder darf, und dazu auch noch Karten gemacht haben, wo sie diese Access Points eingezeichnet haben, sodass jeder der Netz wollte. Es waren damals noch nicht so viele, hat ja auch keine Smartphones und Notebooks selten, aber es gab halt welche. Die konnten dann dort ins Internet. Und dann gab es eine Veranstaltung in Dürsland. Dürsland ist eine Provinz in Dänemark, die ganz, ganz große Strukturprobleme hat. Also das ist sehr, sehr dünn besiedelt, das ist Opendurben, und die hatten da auch gerade für viel Geld einen tollen Glasfaserring gebaut, und dann machte das Kreiskrankenhaus dicht, und dann machte die lokale Zeitung dicht, und dann sagten diese Bürger, oh mein Gott, wir müssen irgendwas tun, sonst gehen wir völlig vor die Hunde, hier zieht keiner mehr hin, hier ziehen alle weg, hier gibt es kein Netz, und Telefon ist auch schwierig, und haben Diosnet begonnen, und dort gab es dann wieder so ein großes Treffen, jetzt hab ich das Treffen in London, und das Chaos lebt auch in mir, und die haben halt tatsächlich einfach mal ihren Landkreis vernetzt, haben sich gesagt, Okay, eine Druckerpresse ist teuer, wir haben diese Faser, wir bohren diese Faser an, haben halt EU-Förderung gekriegt, haben das Ding angebohrt, haben Antennen auf hohe Punkte gesetzt und haben damals vor ich glaube sieben Jahren, fünf Jahren irgendwie so ihre Inlandkreis versorgt mit Netz, mit Intranet, mit internen Diensten und mit Internet und haben damals glaube ich schon 30 Prozent der Bevölkerung versorgt gehabt. Und damit war diese Gegend auch für junge Menschen wieder lebenswert. Und sie haben quasi einfach ihren Landkreis gerettet, weil in einer modernen Gesellschaft ohne Internet geht halt nicht. Und ohne Lokalzeitung ist auch doof. Und dann haben sie halt Server hingestellt und haben dort Lokalzeitung gemacht. Und damit hat einfach ein ganzer Landkreis, eine ganze Region von Dänemark sich selbst aus dem digitalen Abseits befreit und sich selbst angeschlossen. Und das ist eigentlich dieses Grundthema bei Freifunk. Aha, wir sind uninteressant, an uns kann man kein Geld verdienen, uns gibst du kein Internet, interessiert uns nicht, machen wir halt einfach selbst.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, weil das sind sozusagen die geschichtlichen ersten Schritte, aber mittlerweile ist es ja doch so, dass es eigentlich, also ich sage mal zumindest, fast überall in irgendeiner Form Internet gibt. Ist denn Freifunk heutzutage noch tatsächlich eine praktische Lösung oder ist es eher sozusagen Spaß am Basteln und Machen?
Beides, beides. Also ich habe bei mir zu Hause keinen Internetzugang. Der kommt 100 Meter weiter, der wird einfach über die Dächer gefunkt. Ich kann darüber sogar telefonieren. Das geht nur, wenn die Verbindung besser ist. Viele Aktivisten machen das natürlich nicht, um sich selbst zu versorgen, sondern sie machen es für die gute Sache. Sie sagen, es macht Spaß, es ist natürlich Spaß am Gerät und mit Technik spielen und irgendwie in schönen Sommertagen auf 20 Geschässern rumklettern und da Antennen anbringen. Aber es ist halt auch dieses Ding, wir brauchen eine freie Informationsinfrastruktur. Das kann nicht sein, dass alle Straßen privat sind. Und wer die Netzneutralitätsdebatte mitverfolgt hat und diese Zensursgeschichte mitverfolgt hat, der weiß, es ist manchmal sinnvoll, vielleicht den einen Internetanschluss zu benutzen, auch wenn ein anderer in der Nähe ist, weil vielleicht dort zensiert gefiltert, wie auch immer wird und daher...
Generell einen Plan B in der Hand zu haben. Wir hatten heute in Mitte einen Stromausfall und da kam dann auch wieder auf, Mensch, würden wir jetzt WLAN hätten, irgendwie auch noch ein paar Straßen weiter, dann hätten wir zumindest noch Netz. Ich meine, Strom kann man mal darauf verzichten. Hat denn ein Akku im Notebook, aber...
Okay, das heißt, ich nehme dem aber, dass ihr doch nicht angeschlossen seid ins Freifunknetz.
Nee, das kommt noch weiter. Da hat sich ja DSL und Verbreitung vor allem, da sind wir wieder beim Chaos. Man müsste halt mal aufs Dach steigen und man müsste da mal einen Access Point anbringen und man müsste da mal ein Kabel und so weiter und das ist alles ein bisschen schwieriger.
Okay, Access Point und Kabel anbringen und überhaupt wie funktioniert das Ganze, das würde ich sagen, klären wir dann gleich. Wir haben jetzt schon mal gelernt, was Freifunk ist und vor allen Dingen, wo es herkommt. Die technischen Gegebenheiten und warum es ein bisschen komplizierter ist, als ich mache meinen Rechner auf und mache das Ding an, hören wir uns nach den Nachrichten an. Wir hören jetzt noch ein Stück Musik, freie Musik aus dem Netz, dann gibt es Nachrichten und dann machen wir weiter hier im Chaos Radio.
Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da.
Dance or Die Trying ist Creative Commons. Heute Abend am Donnerstag, wie ab jetzt immer, Chaosradio mit Nibbler und Alex, Nibbler vom CCC, Alex von den Freifunkern, denn darum geht es heute um Freifunk. Wir sind einmal quer durch die Geschichte gerockt in 20 Minuten und da sind natürlich viele Auslassungen vorgekommen. Aber wir wissen jetzt ungefähr, woher der Freifunk kommt, nämlich aus einem Datenklo und einem Pömpel, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Und falls ihr es noch mal genauer nachhören wollt, könnt ihr in dem Podcast diese Sendung am Ende hören, dann stellen wir das nämlich alles online. Jetzt wollen wir uns mal damit beschäftigen, wo, also ganz kurz noch klären, wo Freifunk eigentlich sozusagen nicht nur Spaß macht, sondern tatsächlich notwendig ist und dann einfach wie man es macht. Mit dem notwendig wurde hier der Begriff Opalghetto.
Was ist das? Speziell in Berlin, ich weiß nicht, ob das auch in anderen... Alex nickt. Also ich kenn es nur aus der eigenen schmerzlichen Erfahrung. Ja, in Berlin in der Gegend gezogen, und ein Mensch mit uns, okay, schöne Gegend und so weiter, festgestellt, DSL bestellen wollen. Ja, Anbieter kann ich liefern. Nächsten Anbieter gefragt hier, DSL hätte ich gerne. Ja, nee, können wir, also die Straße, da ist nicht. Gut, dann geht man halt doch zum Geb, der mittlerweile Magenta angestrichen wurde und fragt da nach einem DSL. Und ja, nee, wir haben ja so moderne Technologie ausgerollt, so Glasfasertechnik, wir können Ihnen da leider kein schnelles Internet anbieten. Und dann festgestellt, dass es in der Tat im Keller so eine Box gibt, aus der zwar ISDN ausfällt, aber kein Internet.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal genauer nachfragen bei dem Punkt, da geht es um Glasfaserleitung. Und ich habe mal gehört, das ist nicht so, dass es kein Internet über Glasfaser gibt, weil das nicht geht, sondern weil das der Telekom zu teuer ist. Stimmt das oder?
Das ist gut möglich. Also ich weiß zumindest, dass es da Entwicklungen gab über dieses Opal, also die optische Anschlussleitung heißt das, glaube ich. Alex nickt, super.
Du Alex, man kann im Radio nicken übrigens nicht hören. Ich dachte, ich sag's mal.
Ich wollte ja nur bestätigen.
Okay.
Die optische Anschlussleitung. Mir wurde da eine Geschichte erzählt, ich weiß nicht, ob die wahr ist oder nicht. Und was da dran ist, dass halt die Post, die Post, immer wieder die Post, der GILB, die haben halt irgendwie auch schon mal mitgekriegt, dass es dieses Glasfaserzeug gibt und haben ja auch irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer das hieß, Glasfaserleitung in einem Pilotprojekt zwischen großen Städten in Deutschland gemacht. Haben sich dann überlegt, hey, optische Anschlussleitung, ganz toll. Wir machen hier jetzt mal einen Feldtest und haben von, ich glaube, 20, 30, 40, 50 verschiedenen Unternehmen sich also diese Sets gekauft und gesagt, okay, wir machen jetzt einen Feldtest und wir probieren das alles mal aus und evaluieren das und wie das alles so geht und ob wir das wollen und wie wir das machen. So German Engineering. Wir machen das mal mit langer Projektdauer. Und dann, ja, dann kam diese Wende. Und dann waren da plötzlich 16, 8 Millionen Leute, von denen irgendwie eine Million einen Telefonanschluss hatten. Und das war alles Stasi und der Rest hatte keine. Und das war nicht so toll. Und dann musste man ganz schnell Telefonleitungen hinschmeißen. Und dann hatten sie ja irgendwie diese Geräte für diesen Feldtest und haben halt irgendwie wie die Bescheuerten angefangen, diese Technik da zu verbauen. Weil es gibt auch große Unternehmen, die Technik liefern. Aber mal eben ein Land mit 16, 8 Millionen Leuten mit Telefonnetz zu belegen, ist dann doch nichts, was man mal eben macht. Also ist ja nicht so hier in der Besenkammer. Da ist noch drei, vier Vermittlungsstellen. Der Kollege hat noch einen im Schrank im Büro stehen. Und dann stellen wir das mal hin, sondern es ist richtig viel Technik.
Doch, die bestehende Infrastruktur konnte man halt nicht eins zu eins übernehmen, sondern da musste man halt wirklich umbauen. Und da kann das schon ganz gelegen, weil so Glasfaser-Technologie ist ja zukunftssicher und kann ja auch dieses ESDN, was man da so heutzutage als Standard hat und konnte wahrscheinlich auch, weiß nicht, BTX-Anschlüsse an, ich weiß es nicht.
Dieses komische Ding, das braucht ja keiner. Wir haben jetzt gerade hier Andreas in der Leitung. Der wollte uns zum Opal noch was erzählen.
Ja, zu Opal gibt's ein bisschen was zu erzählen. Ich kenne da ein oder zwei Hintergründe. Also es ist richtig, irgendwie Glasfaser, jetzt Opal, optische Anschlussleitung war tatsächlich ein staatlich gefördertes Technologieprojekt. Und der Grund, also theoretisch kann man natürlich über Glasfaser beliebig schnell Internet schieben. Der Grund, warum es nichts schnelleres als ESDN gab, war einfach, dass diese Technologie niemals wirklich gebaut wurde und irgendwie 1991 verbaut wurde und dann so 1997, 1998 wollten die Leute dann plötzlich Internet haben. Und da haben die mich erst einfach gesagt, gibt es seit sieben Jahren nicht, bauen wir auch nicht mehr. Und der Grund, warum die Telekom es nicht rausgeschmissen hat, ist der, dass natürlich solche Anlagen, wenn man die kauft, über einen bestimmten Zeitraum abgeschrieben werden. Bevor die nicht abgeschrieben sind, werfen sie die nicht weg. Und so eine Abschreibungsfrist für eine Telekonservationsanlage liegt bei 15 Jahren. Okay, schön.
Das heißt, die Leute, die in diesem Gebiet leben, die müssen jetzt noch wie lange warten?
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es durch. Man kriegt mittlerweile auch im ehemaligen Opalghetto wieder schnelles Internet.
Puh, Glück gehabt. Aber vielen Dank für den Hintergrund.
Ach doch, einen Hintergrund hab ich noch. Diese Glasfasern wurden an die Kabelunternehmen verkauft, weil da lief auch das Kabelfernsehen drüber. Die Telekom hat da wieder Kupferleitung hinterher gelegt.
In der Tat. Vielen Dank. Bis später. So, hätten wir das also auch geklärt, warum es mit dem Glasfasern und dem Internet so kompliziert ist. Bevor wir jetzt direkt dazu kommen, mal zu erklären, wie wir das jetzt per Freifunk dann in die Opalwüste das Internet hineinkriegen, nehmen wir kurz Lutz ran. Vielleicht klärt sich das ja auch noch von selber.
Lutz?
Du hast eine Frage zum Freifunk.
Genau, ich hätte mal, also erstmal für Felix eine klasse Sache und da willst du ja mitmachen, denn ich weiß, wie es ist, kurzzeitig mal irgendwo zu sein und kein Internet zu haben, obwohl man es eigentlich braucht. Und da hätte ich bloß mal eine Frage, wie das mit den rechtlichen Aspekten ist. Denn es heißt ja, du bist, du bist dafür verantwortlich, dass keiner über deine Internetleitung ins Internet geht. Denn es gibt ja genug Leute, die sich dann einfach mal was runterladen. Und dann bekommst du irgendwann mal die Rechnung von irgendeiner Firma, weil...
Also da kann ich zwei Antworten geben, die beiden jetzt nicht sofort die Antwort geben. Das eine ist, wir haben tatsächlich zu diesem speziellen Thema schon mal ganz ausführlich ein ganzes Chaosradio gemacht. Das ist Chaosradio 157. Da wird das ganz ausführlich erklärt. Wir kommen aber heute auf jeden Fall später im Verlauf der Sendung auch nochmal drauf zu sprechen, dass genau das geklärt wird. Also wenn ich damit mache, welche rechtlichen Sachen, fange ich mir da ein. Wir würden jetzt erstmal klären, wie das technisch überhaupt möglich ist, dass ich da dabei bin. Und dann kommen wir dazu. Wenn wir das hier geklärt haben, noch nicht verständlich, dann rufst du einfach nochmal an.
Ja genau, dann frag mal schnell nach Hause und mach mal hinterher.
Alles klar, mach das. Bis dann, tschüss. So, dann fangen wir jetzt ja an. Freifunk, wie mach ich das? Also weil das Ding ist ja, wenn ich meinen Laptop nehme und in den Kaffee gehe, dann klapp ich das auf und dann geht das WLAN an und dann bin ich im Netz und dann kann jeder meine Facebook- und Twitter-Session klauen, wie wir über Feierstieb gelernt haben in dieser Woche. Dazu sollten wir vielleicht später auch nochmal sprechen, aber erstmal, Freifunk, wie komme ich da ran? Das geht ja nicht so einfach, sondern man braucht dazu irgendwie eine extra Software.
Ja, du brauchst einen Browser. Und der hat da oben so eine Leiste, da kannst du eingeben http://freifunk.net und landest da bei einer Startseite. Und dann ist da eine Liste von unglaublich vielen Städten, Dörfern und Gemeinden, wo es überall schon Communities gibt. Da klickst du dich dann durch, dann findest du die in deiner Nähe und gehst da einfach hin. Ihr habt nämlich meistens so Termine, wo die sich treffen. Dort findest du dann tatsächlich richtige Menschen. Die sind auch alle ganz freundlich. Und erzählen dir dann, dafür brauchst du einen Router. Und dann sagst du, ja cool, hab ich schon. Dann fragen sie dich, ja was für einen. Dann sagst du, ja das weiß ich jetzt aber nicht.
Wait, halt. Bevor wir so weit kommen, ist das schon der Punkt, wenn ich einfach nur in ein Freifunknetz mich einklinken will? Mit meinem Rechner?
Wenn du natürlich ein Freifunknetz vor deiner Hausdürr siehst, sprich du klappst den Rechner auf und du hast da diese Liste von Netzwerken, gibt's glaub ich auch bei Windows, und du siehst da Freifunknetz, dann kannst du dich einfach mit dem verbinden. Und je nachdem, wie der Freifunker in deiner Nachbarschaft drauf ist, kriegst du entweder sofort eine Verbindung oder nicht.
Ach wait, das geht einfach so?
Ja.
Also ich, als ich das letzte Mal, ich muss zugeben, das ist eine Weile her, als ich das letzte Mal probiert hab, mich ein Freifunknetz anzuklinken, hieß es so, ja, also im Prinzip eine gute Idee, du brauchst aber zu dieser besonderen Software, die du vielleicht hier noch und überhaupt.
Ja, also wenn du jetzt bei mir in der Nähe rumstehst und dein Notebook aufmachst, dann kriegst du da eine Verbindung und dann kriegst du eine IP-Adresse und dann machst du dein Browser auf und gehst irgendwie auf die Webseite und dann wirst du umgelenkt. Dann kommst du auf eine andere Webseite und da steht, lieber Benutzer, das hier ist ein Freifunknetz, es gibt hier einige Regeln, bitte kein Filesharing und keine illegalen Handlungen und bitte auch kein unnötiges Streaming, weil wir machen das hier gemeinsam und wir haben nicht so viel Internet, deshalb bitte keinen Missbrauch. Und dann sagst du Accept oder Declan, also du akzeptierst diese Nutzungsbedingungen und es sind Nutzungsbedingungen auch im juristischen Sinne.
Ist das quasi schon jetzt die Frage, die Lutz gerade gestellt hat?
Das geht schon in die Lutz Richtung und dann sagst du Ja und dann wirst du umgelenkt weitergeleitet zu freifunk.net oder wo auch immer der das gerade eingestellt hat und danach kannst du im Internet surfen, normalerweise ungefähr für eine Stunde und dann kommt diese Seite wieder und nervt dich und dann klickst du wieder auf Accept und dann kannst du wieder eine Stunde surfen.
Okay, das heißt jetzt hätte ich sozusagen, um ein Freifunknetz zu nutzen, einfach Rechner auf, also Bedingungen akzeptieren, aber so einfach ist das tatsächlich. Das heißt der Punkt, wo ich zu den netten Leuten gehen muss, die Freifunk mache und die dann wissen wollen, was mein Router für eine Marke ist, das ist der Punkt, wo ich mich dann selber sozusagen für länger in so ein Netz einfinken will. Oder wenn ich da mitmachen will.
Ja, das Ding ist erstmal, wir nennen das ja auch die Nervseite, irgendwann nervt das. Und nach einer Stunde und dann guckst du aber nicht ins Netz und willst aber weiter E-Mail lesen und so weiter und so fort. Ist ja alles völlig blöd. Und dann stellst du fest, ja irgendwie am Fenster hab ich Netz, aber wenn ich auf dem Klo irgendwie News lesen will, dann hab ich plötzlich kein Netz mehr. Und dann ist so der Punkt, wo du anfängst mal rauszufinden, wo treffen sich denn die Freifunker? Und dann triffst du die Freifunker und die erzählen dir dann, ja, gar kein Thema, dafür brauchst du einen Router oder wir geben dir erstmal ein Testgerät und dann kommst du wieder und dann muss man eine spezielle Software auf den Router machen, weil die Router, so wie sie aus dem Supermarktregal kommen, natürlich nicht freifunken können. Und wenn das durch ist, dann stellst du diesen Router bei dir ans Fenster und hast dann eine Verbindung ins Netz. Aber du hast eigentlich noch viel mehr als eine Verbindung. Du bist nämlich dann Teil des Netzes. Du bist Freifunk. Es gibt nämlich bei Freifunk nicht dieses Konzept von ich schließe mich da an, sondern es gibt nur das Konzept von ich werde Teil davon. Und in dem Moment, wo du Teil des Netzes bist, wird das Netz größer. Das wird nämlich um dich erweitert. Und auch stärker und besser und schneller.
Okay, bevor wir jetzt philosophisch werden.
Das reicht auch bis zu deinem Nachbarn, der dein Fenster natürlich nicht hat, über das das Netz reinkommt.
Genau. Plötzlich kann man das nämlich im Hinterhof sehen oder die Wohnung weiter.
Aber nochmal zurück zu dem Router. Du hast ja schon gesagt, man kann jetzt zu den Leuten gehen und kann sich das irgendwie helfen lassen. Vielleicht, wenn man nicht bitte sagt, ein Rehaugen macht, wird das sogar für einen gemacht. Sodass man das Teil einfach da nur hinstellt. Aber was genau passiert denn mit dem Router? Nochmal für den technisch Interessierten Neuling, der vielleicht doch wasen will. Warum genau muss ich jetzt auf dem Router eine Software? Was verändert das da und wozu ist das gut? Er hat mich gebeten eine komplizierte Sache zu erklären, die nicht einfach zu erklären ist. Ist das das Geräusch, was du gerade gemacht hast?
Das ist die Übersetzungsengine Nerd Mensch Mensch Nerd, die da angeworfen wird. Und es gibt da zwei Dinge, die man einmal erklären muss. Der Unterschied zwischen einem Managed Netz und einem Ad-hoc Netz. Und danach muss man noch mal Routing erklären. Und vielleicht Nibbler, kannst du was zum Thema Managed Netz und Ad-hoc Netz erzählen?
Ja, so ein WLAN Access Point, den man sich zu Hause hinstellt, der ist halt so eine Basis Station, wo man sich anmelden kann. Und so eine Basis Station, die kümmert sich um die Verwaltung der einzelnen Teilnehmer. Da meldet man sich halt an mit seinem Notebook. Da meldet sich irgendwie das Netbook mit an und das Telefon. Und die können dann darüber Daten austauschen. Allerdings legt dann da diese Access Point eben fest, wer wann welche Daten austauschen kann und kümmert sich da so ein bisschen um die Ordnung, während die Geräte, die da eingebucht sind, halt nur Geräte sind, die eingebucht sind. Was natürlich in so einem partizipativen Modell, wo halt jeder Teil des Netzes ist und nicht nur so ein Anhängsel, ein bisschen blöd. Weil das ist halt peer to peer. Und da gibt es im WLAN-Standard den sogenannten Ad-hoc-Modus. Und das im Prinzip jedes Gerät, was in diesem Ad-hoc-Modus ist, gleichberechtigt. Und dann teilt sich da sozusagen das Funkmedium und tauscht gleichberechtigt Daten aus.
Das heißt sozusagen, also der normale Router, den ich mir irgendwie im Elektronikmarkt meines Vertrauens gekauft habe, der kann das Internet, das bei mir aus der Dose kommt, verteilen. Kann sich aber nicht gleichzeitig mit anderen Routern darüber abstimmen, wie das jetzt alles funktionieren soll. Und durch diese Software, die aufgespielt wird, wird eben genau das ermöglicht. Also Kommunikation mit anderen gleichartig gestalteten Geräten und eine Abstimmung darüber, wie jetzt Daten ausgetauscht wird.
Genau, dafür benutzt man diesen Asphalt-Modus. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, wenn man irgendwo sitzt und hat diesen Access Point, dann buchen sich alle da ein. Wenn man aber zu dritt mit Notebooks im Park sitzt, wo es keinen Access Point gibt, dann gibt es diesen Ad-Hoc-Modus und dann können alle drei Notebooks miteinander sprechen, wenn man da gerade drei Notebooks hat. Nun ist da natürlich so ein Problem, jetzt mal rein hypothetisch gesprochen. Ich sitze mit meinem Notebook auf so einem Hügel und irgendwie rechts vor mir im Tal sitzt jemand und links vor mir im Tal sitzt jemand. Dann kann ich zwar mit beiden sprechen, aber die rechts und links vor mir können nicht miteinander sprechen. Weil die sehen sich nicht. Die sehen zwar beide mich, aber das hilft nicht. Und deshalb gibt es Routing. Das ist halt so the next big thing zu erklären, das ist immer dieser Brocken. Routing ist, ja was ist Routing eigentlich?
So klassisch im Internet sieht Routing so aus, dass alle Internet-Teilnehmer eben miteinander Daten austauschen wollen und dass in diesem Internet so eine gewisse Ordnung ist, dass man halt weiß, mit wem man da so Daten austauscht und welche Netze man über welches Netz erreichen kann und welche anderen Netzteilnehmer hinter einem Teilnehmer, mit dem man da so eine Verbindung hat, liegen. Das ist eigentlich im Vergleich zu seinem Funknetz eine relativ statische Sache. Da gibt es halt Teilnehmer, die neu dazukommen, Teilnehmer, wo halt gerade mal der Link aber abbricht. Aber so im Prinzip ist das was, was man ausfest zusammengestapselten Kabeln, also das Internet ist im Prinzip ja so eine Zusammenrottung von Leuten, die untereinander Kabel gesteckt haben. Bei so einem Funknetz ist das natürlich schwieriger, weil da gibt es auch keinerlei Mirarchie. Man kann sich jetzt nicht irgendwie an einen ISP ranhängen, der gibt einem dann Internet weiter und so weiter, sondern da braucht man Protokoll, was zwischen den einzelnen Teilnehmern vermittelt und allen Teilnehmern mitteilt, wie so die Topologie aussieht, wie die Pakete in diesem Netz geroutet werden müssen, also weitergereicht werden müssen, damit die Daten auch da ankommen, wo sie hin sollen. Und das sogenannte Mesh-Routing-Protokolle.
Ja, es ist nämlich so eine Sache. Wir haben jetzt diese drei Notebooks, um mal diesen Bild mit dem Hügel und dem Menschen rechts von mir und dem Menschen links von dir zu bleiben. Und jetzt müssen wir erst mal voneinander wissen, dass wir existieren. Und unsere Notebooks müssen das auch. Ich kann also irgendwie rumbrüllen, Hallo, und dann hören mich die beiden. Und die können auch Hallo zurückrufen. Und dann haben wir auf der akustischen Ebene schon mal geklärt, dass wir da sind. Und die Notebooks machen bei einem solchen Mesh-Routing-Protokoll dasselbe. Das heißt, alle paar Sekunden schmeißt er ein Paket an alle. Da steht Hallo drin. Da steht tatsächlich, das sind die sogenannten Hello-Pakete. Und da steht auch noch eine Adresse drin. Und der Kollege auf der einen Seite und der Kollege auf der anderen, sie machten das Gleiche. Und auf die Art und Weise können wir schon mal feststellen, okay, wir sind zu dritt. So. Und auch der im Tal kann feststellen, okay, da ist ja noch jemand in einem anderen Tal. Und wenn ich mit dem reden will, dann muss ich das Paket an den Hügel schicken. Und der Typ auf dem Hügel hat auch einen gewissen Überblick und checkt das Paket dann zu dem anderen Menschen im Tal. Das ist dieses Mesh Routing. Das heißt, wir müssen A, erkennen, Neighbor Discovery machen. Wir müssen erkennen, wer sind unsere Nachbarn und wie gut hören wir die und wie schlecht hören wir die. Und wir müssen die Topologie erkennen. Das heißt, den gesamten Aufbau dieses Netzes. Ich muss halt rausfinden, welchem Nachbarn muss ich ein Paket zuwerfen, damit er es zum Ziel bringen kann.
Ich muss sagen, das erinnere mich gerade an dieses, es gibt doch diese Geschichte irgendwie, wie jeder kennt jeden Menschen auf der Welt um sieben Ecken, wo dieses Experiment, wo man sozusagen einen Brief irgendwie ein Einen gibt und der bringt es dann irgendwann zu Michael Jackson nicht mehr, weil der ist ja schon aber halt, ne? Das ist im Prinzip dieses Ding. Also meine Daten werden nicht mehr direkt übergeben, sondern ich muss nur rausfinden, an weniges werfen muss, damit es dann letztendlich da ankommt, wo es hin soll. Und das ist auch das, was der Router lernt, wenn ich ihm diese Software aufspiele.
Genau, wir spielen da stille Post mit WLAN.
Okay, aber die Ergebnisse sind hoffentlich besser als bei der stillen Post.
Ja, das liegt daran, dass es so Protokolle wie 802.11, also WLAN, gibt, die Pakete wiederholen, wenn sie kaputt gehen. Und es gibt Protokolle wie TCP, die das gleiche noch mal auf einer höheren Ebene machen. Und gelegentlich gibt es auch Routing Loops, dann laufen die Pakete im Kreis, weil halt irgendjemand... Das ist auch eine der Herausforderungen, weil wenn sich jemand bewegt in dem Ganzen, dann müssen alle rechtzeitig wissen, dass der sich bewegt hat, sonst laufen Pakete im Kreis. Genau, Routing Loops, ganz ganz schlimm. Mesh Routing Protokoll Entwickler können da irgendwie furchtbare Albträume von kriegen.
Das heißt, wenn ich jemanden kenne, der Mesh Netze entwickelt, oder Mesh Routing entwickelt, und ich ihm rufe Routing Loop, dann fängt er an zu spasten und fällt um?
Er guckt dich völlig irritiert an und sehr panisch.
Ich finde, das ist auch immer eine wichtige Sache, die man hier am Chaosradio lernen kann, wie man Leute verschiedener Kolorien Wahnsinn treibt. Das ist auch eine sehr wichtige Information, die auch in dem Chaos in uns, was hier öfter mal aufgetaucht ist, ganz wichtig ist. Jetzt wissen wir also, wozu wir diese Software brauchen, die auf dem Router draufgespielt wird. Und wie gesagt, wenn man da mitmachen will, kann man zu euch gehen. Und sich dabei so helfen lassen, dass man im Prinzip gar keine Ahnung von braucht. Aber wie schwierig und kompliziert ist denn, das selber zu machen?
Ja, jetzt haben wir erstmal wieder mal einen Abstecher in die Geschichte. Und es geht mal wieder ins Chaos. Ist ja klar, weil dieses Chaos ist Mutter aller Dinge. Dann gab es diese Hersteller von Routern. Wir nennen die auch Plastorouter, also diese praktischen kleinen Access Points. Und das ist die Firma Linksys gewesen. Inzwischen gehört sie der Firma Cisco. Und die haben halt so einen Router verkauft. Und dann haben mal Leute rausgefunden, auf dem Router läuft ja Linux. Aber dafür gibt es ja gar keinen Quellcode. Und Linux ist ja unter dieser GPL, unter der GNU Public License. Und wenn man GPL-Software mitgibt, dann muss man ja auch einen Quellcode dazugeben.
Das ist eben das Besondere an der GPL. Normalerweise sind so Lizenzen, zumindest historisch, da, um die Software zu beschränken. Um zu sagen, du darfst mit der Software aber nur das und das und das machen. Und du musst das und das und das machen. Und die GPL dreht den ganzen Spieß um und sagt, wenn du diese Software verwendest, dann musst du den Quellcode dieser Software weitergeben. Und wenn du sie veränderst, dann musst du deine Änderungen auch offenlegen. Was also sozusagen die Lizenz ist, die für den Benutzer, also die Benutzerrechte stärkt und nicht die dessen, der diese Software quasi verbreitet.
Diese Firma hat halt Linux verwendet, um das Betriebssystem für einen Router zu bauen, hat aber nicht die GPL eingehalten. Das hat aber jemand mitgekriegt und daraufhin haben sie quasi eine Anklage? Oder wie lebt das denn?
Na, es gibt da, was war das, Harald? gplviolations.org glaube ich. Da ist mittlerweile, die haben sich das mittlerweile zum Hobby gemacht sozusagen. Aber es hat auch immer mehr.
Das ist so eine Art Abmahnanwalt für die gute Sache, oder wie?
Die Rechte der Benutzer. Im Prinzip ist das auch im Sinne der Firma, die so Geräte vertreibt, weil es schon ziemlich cool ist, wenn man eine Community hat, die eben an der Software weiterentwickelt. Wenn man sich aus der Community so Software ausleitet, in Anführungszeichen, und die selbst weiterentwickelt, warum sollte man da nicht der Community was zurückgeben und gegenseitig davon profitieren? Also das ist schon eine schöne Richtung, in die das Ganze da geht. Weil jeder davon, was hat das hier, Geräte entwickelt werden. Der Hersteller kann seine Geräte verkaufen. Und das ist glaube ich auch das, was dann bei Linksys passiert ist. Das Gerät hat eine unglaubliche Beliebtheit erlangt. Also es ist so der erste, der prototypische Plastirouter mit einem selber Baubetriebssystem drauf gewesen, wo man halt wirklich in so einem kleinen günstigen Gerät mal ja selbst rumbasteln konnte. Nicht nur an der Hardware oder so, sondern auch an der Software. Und einem das halt völlig offen lag, mit dem Gerät zu tun, was man möchte. Und das war im Fall der Freifunkerheit frei zu funken.
Das war quasi also das erste Gerät, womit das so richtig praktisch und gut ging.
Ja, es gab damals von 4G Systems den MeshCube, der war super Hightech und super teuer. Und es gab von Linksys den VAT. Der VAT 54G hieß er damals. Und plötzlich war es möglich, für 60, 70 Euro ein Gerät zu bekommen. Das hatte WLAN, da lief ein Linux drauf und damit konnte man basteln. Und das haben unglaublich viele Leute getan. Und dann gab es die verschiedensten Linux-Distributionen für Router. Das gab Tomato-WRT und Didi-WRT und ganz wichtig Open-WRT. Damals entstand das alles. Und mit diesen Geräten und mit diesem VAT war die Grundlage geschaffen, um eine Firmware zu bauen. Man muss dazu sagen, wenn man so ein Gerät hat und das hat keinen Bildschirm und keine Tastatur, sondern nur ein paar Anschlüsse, dann nennt man die Software, die da drauf läuft, Firmware.
Es ist aber im Prinzip, um es mal ganz einfach zu formulieren, nichts anderes als so eine Art Findus für den Router.
Ja genau, das ist so ein System, was läuft da drauf. Das ist auch ein Rechner, der hat einen 200 MHz CPU, der hat 16 MB RAM, der hat auch ein bisschen Flashspeicher, der hat Ethernet, hat WLAN, das ist eigentlich nur ein Computer. Und wenn man ein bisschen lötet, dann hat der sogar eine Konsole.
Und das, wo man irgendwie Text reinwerfen kann und Text rausfällt.
Ja, wie man den bedienen kann. Und die Leute haben alle möglichen Dinge mitgemacht, die haben die umgebaut zu MP3-Playern, die haben damit Klobeleuchtung gesteuert, die haben damit Daten übertragen, sowieso.
Das Schickste, was ich mal gesehen hab, war so ein fahrbarer VAT, wo man irgendwie so Räder drunter hatte und dann nach vorne diese klassischen zwei Antennen mit einer Kamera dran, der dann eben durch die Gegend gefahren ist und die man über WLAN fernsteuern konnte.
Die waren auch auf der H.
Das gibt es auch als fliegend.
Der BRT wurde quasi der C64 der Neuzeit. Wo man am C64, muss man sagen, das war ein Homecomputer, da hatte den Userport, da konnte man alles Mögliche anschließen. Das hieß immer, wenn es einen C64 Freak mit einem Düstentriebwerk gegeben hätte, dann hätte es auch ein Düstentriebwerksinterface für C64er gegeben.
Okay, jetzt gibt es also diese Router und da kann man dieses Betriebssystem drauf spielen. Und das ist jetzt genau wie schwierig?
Ja, das ist gar nicht so schwierig. Es gibt nämlich den Sven Ola. Der Sven Ola hat sich dann mal hingesetzt und hat das damalige OpenWRT genommen und hat daraus die Freifunkfirmware gemacht. Das heißt, er hat dieses Unix, dieses Linux genommen und hat dann eine schicke Benutzeroberfläche, so ein Webinterface gebaut, was auch Freifunkstyle aussieht und mit Hilfetexten und so weiter und so fort und Voreinstellungen. Und das kann man ganz einfach über das Webinterface seines Routers darauf flaschen. Sprich, man sagt Firmware Update und statt Firmware Update macht man Firmware Austausch. Und wenn man das gemacht hat, da muss man halt eine Datei hochladen, kennt man vielleicht auch von seiner Fritzbox, wo man das auch machen kann. Und das gemacht hat, dann dauert das fünf Minuten und dann kommt der Router zurück und plötzlich steht da nicht mehr Linksys, sondern da steht da Freifunk.
Und dann habe ich das Ding da aufgespielt und mache es an, stellte es ins Netz oder muss ich dann noch irgendwie mich durch irgendwelche Einstellungen kämpfen?
Ja, früher war es ein Kampf, inzwischen geht es. Du musst dir dann halt noch eine IP klicken. In Berlin gehst du dann auf ip.berlin.freifunknet, meldest dich da an, sagst, liebes Freifunk, ich hätte gerne eine IP-Adresse. Dann dachte, hier hast du eine IP-Adresse. Dann füllst du die da ein und sagst okay. Und dann dauert das wieder ein bisschen und dann sollte das eigentlich funktionieren. Es gibt da so eine Checkliste und wenn alle Häkchen gesetzt sind, dann ist dein Router konfiguriert.
Alles klar. Und falls sich an irgendeiner Stelle ein Gerät, kann man bricken? Brick von einem Ziegelstein vom Englischen, wenn irgendwas schief geht, dann sozusagen ist es funktionsunfähig. Kann man sich einen Router, wenn man selber bastelt, wirklich ganz kaputt machen damit?
Man sollte halt den Strom nicht rausziehen, wenn man da gerade Firmware aktualisiert. Das ist immer ganz schlecht. Aber ansonsten?
Also man kann den Aufwand zum De-Breaken erhöhen.
Okay, aber im Zweifelsfall kann ich mit dem geprägten Router immer zu euch kommen und ihr habt dann noch eine Lösung? Meistens. Okay, also wenn man nicht ganz risikofreudig ist, dann doch lieber gleich zu euch. Dann nehm ich den.
Es ist ziemlich schwer die Dinger kaputt zu kriegen. Ich hab einen Router in den letzten 7 Jahren gesehen, die wir nicht wieder hingekriegt haben.
Er hat viele Router gesehen.
Er hat viele Router gesehen. Heute Chaosradio mit dem Thema Freifunk. Was bedeutet, dass wir uns mal ausführlicher damit beschäftigen, wie man Netz dorthin kriegt, wo es nicht ist. Und wie man Netz zu ganz vielen Leuten kriegt, die sich zusammengetan haben. Wir haben jetzt schon die Geschichte geklärt, was dazu notwendig ist an Technik und was man dazu braucht. Wir werden uns gleich mal ein bisschen mit der praktischen Umsetzung, also was man damit macht, mit dem Recht, das war ja auch eine kurze Frage, beschäftigen. Vorher gibt es ein kleines Stück Musik, die ihr euch auch aus dem Netz ziehen könnt und die kommt von Bitcrunch. Bitcruncher, House of Opiukos heißt es, Link dazu zum runterladen. Du gibt es im Wiki zur Sendung. Chaosradio.ccc.de ist auch Creative Commons Musik und solltet euch mal anhören, ist nämlich von Professor Click empfohlen und die Leute, die sich ein bisschen Netzmusik auskennen, wissen, was das bedeutet. Das bedeutet nämlich, es muss total geil sein. Wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit dem Chaos Radio, wo Nibbler vom CCC und Alex von den Freifunkern zu Gast sind, weil wir heute nämlich genau über Freifunk sprechen. Wir haben uns schon ein bisschen was geklärt. Was ist Freifunk eigentlich? Ach so, du könntest eigentlich nochmal, Alex, noch eine Definition dazu bringen, weil du meinest, es gibt irgendwie ganz viele Definitionen, wahrscheinlich mehr Definitionen, als es überhaupt Freifunker gibt. Aber was ist Freifunk eigentlich?
Es geht um den Aufbau von freier Informationsinfrastruktur, in diesem Fall von Funknetzen, in denen jeder, der Freifunk hat, nicht nur Teilnehmer, sondern Netzinfrastruktur ist.
Das heißt, man zieht das Wille ja nicht nur, sondern stellt es gleichzeitig auch noch für andere bereit. Wir haben jetzt im Laufe dieser Sendung schon geklärt, wo das herkommt, also geschichtlich, da ging es um Datenklots, dann haben wir geklärt, was man machen muss, um daran teilzunehmen. Es geht relativ einfach, wenn man einfach ins Netz will, wenn man knallt den Rechner auf und lockt sich ein und klickt eine Einverständniserklärung, dass man keinen Unsinn macht und wenn man selber das ganze Netz teilen will, also mit anderen auch mitteilen will, dann stellt man sich einen Router, der auf eine besondere Art und Weise behandelt wurde, ins Fenster. Das heißt, wir wissen jetzt schon im Kleinen, wie man das macht. Im Großen ist es ja so, aber auch so ein Freifunknetz muss irgendwo hinkommen. Da ist es gerade schön mit den Worten beschrieben, wie versorge ich ein Dorf mit Freifunk? Das ist ja auch ganz praktisch, wenn es da zum Beispiel hier in Brandenburg, nicht so selten leider, Orte gibt, wo es gar kein Netz gibt. Wie versorgt man denn jetzt so ein Dorf mit Freifunk?
Ja, es gibt eine ganze Menge Dörfer, die nicht ans Internet angebunden sind, zumindest nicht breitbandig. Das ist halt auch immer so eine Kostengeschichte. Und der Mensch ist ja nur wert, was man an ihm verdienen kann, zumindest wenn es um Internetversorgung geht. Und da sind halt ganz wenige Menschen und die sind ziemlich weit ab vom Schuss. Und das sind lange Kabel und viel Technik, die man da braucht. Und das ist natürlich viel schöner, in den Ballungsgebieten Netz anzubieten. Und was man da macht, ist Folgendes. Man tut sich zusammen und man sucht in der Nähe des Ortes, in dem man da wohnt, Internet. Das ist relativ einfach. Es gibt da diese Verfügbarkeitsprüfung. Und guckt mal in den Nachbardörfern und in den Nachbarstädten. Und früher oder später wird man feststellen, 8 Kilometer entfernt oder 7 Kilometer oder 12 Kilometer entfernt gibt es ja schon Internet. Da findet man dann meistens dann 4 MBit oder 6 MBit DSL. Das kann man auch relativ einfach machen. Es gibt da diese Verfügbarkeitsprüfung von diesen verschiedenen Anbietern. Die wollen immer, dass man eine Telefonnummer angibt. Deshalb sucht man sich auf die Telefonnummer der Dorfkneipen raus und gibt die da ein.
Jetzt wisst ihr, warum Kneipen ein Telefon haben. Nicht nur mal mit dem Würst namens Scherze zu treiben, nein. Auch damit ihr nachschlagen könnt, ob es dort Internet gibt.
Genau, und dann weißt du ziemlich schnell. Dann suchst du dir den höchsten Punkt im Dorf oder im Dorf näher raus. Das kann ein Kirchturm sein, das kann ein Getreidesilo sein. Das kann irgendetwas hohes sein. Du stellst dich da oben rauf und machst mal einen schicken Panoramachot. So richtig einmal mit der großen Spiegelreflex rumdrehen und kannst dann, das tust du bei klarem Wetter, einfach mal sehen, was man sieht.
Man muss das so sagen, so Kirchen sind prädestiniert dafür. Das sind grundsätzlich immer hohe Gebäude mit überwiegend freundlichen Leuten drin.
Ja und die haben auch noch Sendungsbewusstsein. Schon länger als das Freifunk. Und sie sind häufig auf Hügeln gebaut. Das kommt ja noch dazu. Sogar in Berlin. Und dann wirst du feststellen, das Dorf da hinten, da gibt es ja Netz und da gibt es auch einen hohen Punkt. So und dann gehst du da hinten und sprichst mal mit den Leuten, sagst du, ja wir machen hier gerade so eine Bürgerinitiative, wir wollen nämlich ans Internet und du hast da dieses schöne Gebäude, diesen Schornstein und wir würden gerne also bei dir einen DSL-Anschluss legen lassen und mal ein Kabel auf deinen Schornstein. Und dann sagt der Wut, was willst du denn? Dann sagt er, ja guck mal hier Freifunk, Richtfunk und so weiter und das tut gar nicht weh. Und jetzt kann man ungefähr drei Monate Kommunikation und interne Abstimmung überspringen und baut dann Geräte und zwar baut man an sein Kirchturmgerät oder an seinen Getreidesilo und das ist so eine Richtfunktechnik und dann baut man am anderen Ende ein Gerät und dann setzt man dort noch einen Router hin und dann hat man auch ohne Probleme über 8 km, über 12 km, wenn da kein Hügel zwischen ist, eine Funkverbindung.
Könnten wir noch ein bisschen genauer spezifizieren, was heißt ein Gerät an den Kirchturm bauen?
Ja, also noch vor drei Jahren war das alles furchtbar aufwendig und anstrengend. Da gibt es auch ganz ganz schicke Bilder unter Freifunknet. Da sieht man dann so Schaltkästen mit jede Menge Technik drin und Geräte und Antennenkabel und Anschlussadapter und so weiter. Inzwischen gibt es Unternehmen, die kleine praktische handliche Hardware für wenig Geld herstellen. Das heißt, man hat dann so eine Plastikbox, die hat so eine Aufnahme, damit man die mit zwei Kabelbindern an den Rohr oder an den Masten festmachen kann. Da steckt man noch ein Kabel rein. Das Strom kommt auch über dieses Kabel. Und da läuft, man glaubt es kaum, eine Freifunkfirmae drauf.
Und sozusagen so ein Plastorouter, nur genau für den Zweck optimiert, wo man halt eine Antenne dran hat, die entsprechend gerichteter ist. Also gerichtet, wenn man das halt gerade braucht. Früher musste man sich diese Antennen noch entweder ganz, ganz, ganz teuer kaufen oder aus Chips-Dosen selber bauen und dergleichen mehr. Und das war natürlich alles so ein bisschen Frickelkram, weil je günstiger man das haben möchte, je mehr man verbauen möchte, desto mehr leidet dann auch da die Qualität. Und wenn man jetzt einfach so sich das im Netz klicken kann für schmales Geld, dann hält das auch den nächsten Winter.
Also schmales Geld heißt in dem Fall was?
Deutlich unter 100 Euro pro Gerät. Also halt schon so im Segment, wo man auch gehobene Plastorouter finden würde.
Okay, und das ist die Antenne, die das Signal austrahlt?
Na, das ist schon gleich ein Access Point, wo halt so ein Linux drin läuft. Diese Freifunkfirmen wir auch mit einer eingebauten Antenne. Sprich, man hat dann auch gar kein Problem mit Kabeln und Kabelverlust. Und da gibt es auch nicht nur einen Hersteller, der das herstellt. Ich hab irgendwie gestern mal wieder umgeklickt. Also da gibt es ja mittlerweile einiges.
Es gibt da für 80 bis 100 Euro pro Ende Geräte und das ist alles schon fertig.
Also sowohl für das eine als auch für das andere Ende gibt es schon die fertigen Geräte. Das heißt, ich lege mir also sagen in dem Dorf, das schon Internet hat, nur ein kleines gallisches Dorf, das hat schon Internet. Und da baue ich diese eine Box ran und klick mir dann Internetanschluss für. Und der funk dann sozusagen direkt über, was ist die maximale Entfernung? Sind das diese 12 Kilometer, die du gerade genannt hast?
Ja, das ist eine Frage. Also es ist, wenn du hohe Türme hast, kannst du auch 20 Kilometer funken. Wenn du nicht so hohe Türme hast, kannst du 8 bis 12 Kilometer funken. Wenn du Hügel dazwischen hast, wird es schwieriger. Wenn du keine Hügel hast, einfacher. In Venezuela haben sie mal mit völlig übertriebenem Aufwand 240 Kilometer gefunkt.
Das ist dann aber nicht mehr für unter 100 Euro zu machen.
Das war eine 3-Meter-Satellitenschüssel oder sowas.
Wir merken uns sozusagen bei freier Sicht, 8 Kilometer kein Problem.
Kein Problem, 8 Kilometer.
Alles andere müsste man so experimentell machen.
Das war aber auch nicht immer so, dass man so wirklich große Distanzen überbrücken kann, weil dieser WLAN-Standard eine kleine Fiesheit hatte, die natürlich die Hersteller und gleich in meinem Spezifizieren als Stolperstein in den Weg gelegt haben. Das war diese Geschichte mit dem AX.
Ja, das gibt halt einen Zeitraum, wo die Bestätigung für das Paket kommen muss. Das sind ein paar Mikrosekunden und das Licht ist halt nicht so schnell. Deshalb war die Reichweite, wenn man sich an die Spezifikation gehalten hat, auf maximalen Kilometer begrenzt oder sowas.
Ach so, ich dachte ja, wie in diesen Plastokästen ist was anderes als WLAN, aber es ist tatsächlich einfach nur WLAN, was sozusagen gebündelt wird. Aber trotzdem habe ich am anderen Ende dann auch ein bestimmtes Gerät, was das empfängt und dann wieder weiter verteilt. Oder sozusagen einfach, ok.
Also heute sind das Geräte, die in 5, 8 Gigahertz Band funken. Es gibt ja so verschiedene Frequenzen und das, was du in deinem Notebook drin hast, kann wahrscheinlich beides, nämlich 2, 4 und 5 Gigahertz. Mein Notebook hier kann nur 2, 4 Gigahertz und die Geräte, die wir da verwenden, funken eigentlich alle bei 5 Gigahertz.
Anders als um das sogenannte ISM Band, also Industrial Standards and Magic oder so. Was ein freies Band ist, 2, 4 Gigahertz wurde da bewusst gewählt, weil das auch der Bereich ist in dem normale Mikrowellenöfen. Und das will man eh für Funk nicht so richtig und für zuhause geht das. Und der Ticke an dem 5 Gigahertz Band ist, dass man da eben nicht diese Mikrowellenöfen hat, sondern dass man das weitestgehend für sich alleine hat.
Also ich hab jetzt letztens bei einem WLAN-Scan auf einem 13 Geschösser oder so was mal ein anderes Netzwerk gesehen mit 5 Gigahertz. Das Band ist also so bei den Dächern Berlins noch frei. Wenn ich das mit 2, 4 Gigahertz mach, dann hab ich glaube ich in zwei Sekunden 300 bis 400 Exosyphons, die ich sehen kann. Also das ist frei dadurch, dass es eine andere Wellenlänge hat, für die Fresnelzone nicht so groß.
Und auch die Ausbreitung ist, also je höher so eine Frequenz ist, ist die Ausbreitung immer mehr wie Licht. Sprich so ein 2, 4 Gigahertz Netz geht natürlich eher durch Wände durch als 5 Gigahertz. Sieht man auch bei Mobiltelefonen, Nagezeitenetze, die 900 MHz funken und welche, die in 1, 8 Gigahertz funken. Und erstere kann man auch noch im Keller empfangen an die mit 1800 MHz nicht. Aber das hat sich jetzt eher angeglichen, weil sie da noch mal ein bisschen umverteilt haben und da sind neue Frequenzen dazugekommen. Aber das nur am Rande.
Okay, also ich habe jetzt diese beiden Plastikkästen, die es extra dafür gebaut zu kaufen gibt, unter 100 Euro pro Stück. Und habe also von einem Dorf, wo ich dann dieses L-Anschluss habe, das in mein anderes Dorf geschickt. Und da baue ich dann am Ende sozusagen einfach einen ganz normalen Netzverteilungsinfrastruktur dran. Also Router oder Kabel oder wie auch immer, um das in die einzelnen Häuser zu bekommen.
Ja, einen Kabel zu verlegen ist ein bisschen übertrieben, wenn man gerade über acht Kilometer gefunkt hat. Kann man auch buddeln. Ja, was man macht ist, man baut dann nochmal einfach drei Antennen mit Mesh-Routern dran, also wieder mit Freifunk-Routern dran und richtet die in die drei Richtungen oder vier. Kann man sich aussuchen, je nachdem wie viel man da macht. Und dann stellt sich jeder irgendwie so ein kleines Gerät aufs Dach oder ins Fenster oder wie auch immer. Und hat da wieder dieses klassische Mesh-Netz. Das heißt, wenn mein Nachbar den Kirchturm sehen kann und ich ihn nicht sehen kann, dann funke ich halt über meinen Nachbarn. Und dies haben tatsächlich Leute gemacht. Da gibt es, spontan fällt mir der Freifunk Gado ein, aber da gibt es eine ganze Menge Dörfer, die inzwischen nicht mehr nur ihr eigenes Dorf versorgen, sondern die haben inzwischen weitere Funkstrecken gebaut zu anderen Dörfern, die auch kein Internet haben und die sie über ihre Internetleitung auch noch mit versorgen. Das heißt, da entsteht wiederum sowas wie ein Mesh-Netzwerk, wo dann die einzelnen Dörfer quasi knoten sind.
Wie ist denn das jetzt? Also die eine Frage, die mir zu einfällt ist, ich habe diese lange Funkstrecke über diese acht Kilometer, ist die abhängig vom Wetter? Also kann man da irgendwie, wenn es neblig ist, ist die Verbindung nicht so gut oder ist das relativ stabil?
Das ist relativ stabil.
Und die andere ist, was ist denn die Mindestvoraussetzung für den Anschluss, den ich da haben muss, damit es irgendwie einigermaßen Netz für alle gibt?
Ja, einigermaßen Netz. Man muss sich immer mal vorstellen, das ist für mich ganz schwer vorstellbar, man sitzt da und Netz heißt irgendwie Modem oder ISDN. Da kommen 64 Kilobit durch. Und wenn nicht das Mündel kommen 128 durch. Das heißt, wenn in diesem Dorf ein 2 Mbit Anschluss ist, dann können sich den durchaus 20 Leute teilen. Das ist gar kein Thema, das können auch 40. Dann hat man zwar noch nicht YouTube, aber man hat zumindest schon mal Mail und man hat Mails lesen und Mails senden und Websurfen ohne dass irgendwie gleich alles im Schneckentempo läuft. Wenn ich jetzt 40 Leute habe, sind 6 Mbit natürlich besser. Aber über 6 Mbit kann man auch ohne Probleme 40 bis 60 Leute abfackeln. Über eine 16 Mbit kann man also in der Vergangenheit 250 bis 300 Blogger mit Internet versorgen. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das das Äquivalent zu irgendwie 5 Dörfern in Brandenburg ist.
Aber es ist schon sozusagen, also man soll einfach das Größte nehmen.
Man nimmt, was man kriegen kann.
Je größer hat, desto komfortabler.
Wenn man ein Mbit kriegt, dann nimmt man ein Mbit. Wenn man 16 kriegt, nimmt man 16.
All right, gut, wir haben jetzt hier Lutz. Der hat eine Frage zum Netzaufbau. Wollen wir ihn gleich mit reinnehmen? Du bist doch derselbe hier von vorhin, oder? Alles klar. Du hattest noch eine Frage zum Netzaufbau.
Genau. Mal angenommen, ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel eine 2 MB, also Megabyte-Leitung und will jetzt nicht an dieses Freifunknetz mit rankehren, also als Geber. Und will ich jetzt aber nicht die kompletten 2 MB geben, kann ich denn einstellen, dass jetzt zum Beispiel von meiner Internetverbindung 1, 5 oder 1 MB an diese Freifunk geht und das andere behalte ich selber?
Ja, das geht. Und zwar ist das der Menüpunkt Netzwerk Firewall QoS und da kannst du dann 1 MB einstellen und dann wird dein Router nur 1 MB abgeben.
Und dann wegen der Reichweite, ich wohne ja in Oranienburg zum Beispiel und da sind ja hohe Häuser und ich wohne jetzt nicht ganz so hoch, ich wohne da in einem Einfamilienhaus nah am Rande und ja, was wäre denn so eine, also ich kann mir jetzt keinen Turm leisten, dass ich da jetzt ihn hinbaue und dann jetzt noch ein paar...
Man muss Opfer bringen.
Denn ich kann mir jetzt vorstellen, wenn ich den jetzt aufstelle, dass der dieselbe Reichweite hat wie ein ganz normaler WLAN.
Ja, da besorgst du dir ein paar Spackschrauben und Dachlatten im Baumarkt und baust du einen Turm. Nein, generell kannst du oben an den Antennenmasten ran und kannst mal in die eine oder andere Richtung funken. Und damit kommst du schon ganz schön weit. Und wenn du ein Hindernis hast und das ein Wohnhaus ist, dann kannst du ja auch mal Zettel in den Briefkasten werfen oder an das schwarze Brett hängen und Mitstreiter suchen und dann hast du plötzlich jemand in einem höheren Haus, der macht mit. Und wenn der mitmacht, dann leitet er das ja schon wieder weiter, weil jeder der mitmacht, vergrößert das Netz ja.
Also wie ist das mit Repeatern zum Beispiel? Die vergrößern ja auch teilweise die Reichweite. Kann man da ein paar Repeater zwischenklemmen?
Jeder Freifunkrouter ist so was wie ein Repeater++ on steroids. Also Repeater sind ziemlich dumme Geräte, die einfach nur repeaten und die Freifunkrouter machen Repeater Deluxe. Und das Freifunknetz ist quasi ein Netz, was nur noch aus Repeatern besteht. Das heißt, wenn dein Kumpel in dem hohen Haus 300 Meter weiter, den du sehen kannst, so ein Ding aufstellt, dann ist der Repeater und du bist Repeater. Und der kann wieder einen Kumpel sehen, der den sieht. Und schon habt ihr ein Netz und könnt dort irgendwie Dinge drin machen.
Und wenn ich jetzt, also ich möchte jetzt da einen Teil nehmen und jetzt hol ich mir einen Router und schick euch den, dass ihr da die Firmware aufspielt und ja, und dann kriegt ihr ihn zurück sozusagen.
Das kannst du selber machen. Da kannst du im Router auf Firmware Update klicken und dann nimmst du nicht die Firmware vom Hersteller, sondern eine Freifunkfirmware.
Kann man sich die dann von der Hinterseite runterladen?
Ja, da gibt es dann auch eine Liste der unterstützten Hardware.
Die Reihenfolge ist die, erst auf die Webseite gehen, dann dort gucken, welche Router unterstützt werden, dann einen davon kaufen, den mit der Firmware bespielen und dann loslegen.
Gut, okay, super, dann werden mir die Fragen schon mal antwortet.
Alles klar, dann viel Spaß damit. Eine Sache, die mir jetzt aber noch auffällt, ist Lutzburg in Oranienburg, also am Rande von Berlin. Da gibt es ja wahrscheinlich Netz. Um das mal klarzumachen, wenn es in einer Gegend schon Netz gibt, also einfach quasi, für jeden verfügbar, dann ist es eher eine Sache für Idealisten, um dort nochmal Freifunk hinzulegen.
Na, man kann eine ganze Menge mit Freifunk machen. Also ich bekomme über Freifunk mein Internetzugang. Das ist irgendwie so meine Grundversorgung. Aber Kumpel von mir, der halt irgendwie drei Straßen weiter wohnt, ist halt DJ und hat eine ultrafette MP3-Sammlung. Und diese MP3-Sammlung hat er halt auf so einem kleinen Server. Und natürlich habe ich auf diesem Server einen Account und kann irgendwie die Musik abspielen. Der hat nämlich einen kleinen Streaming-Server und ich kann halt bei mir in der Küche sitzen und der streamt halt einfach über das Freifunknetz von dem Server meines Kumpels.
Musikstreamen vom anderen, ist das illegal?
Ja, aber selbstverständlich. Ich meine, wir sind persönlich bekannt. Da ist ein Passwort vor und es geht auch ohne. Und das ist die ganz normale Privatkopie. Wenn ich den jetzt nicht kennen würde oder der im Internet ist, dann wäre das ja offensichtlich illegal. Aber ich kenne den, wir sind gleich ein Piraten-Crew. Der hat das wahrscheinlich auch alles gekauft, weil der hat einfach Platten.
Er hat das natürlich alles gekauft. Ich möchte meine Frage noch mal dahingehend spezifizieren. Wenn ich in einem Gebiet wohne, wo Internet sehr gut verfügbar ist, macht das keinen Sinn, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen als Alleiniger Freifunker da anfange. Sondern dann ist es wirklich eine Sache, da suche ich mir ein paar Leute und baue dann nochmal ein Freifunknetz auf. Genau. Diese Netzverteilungsgeschichte ist dann eher sekundär, weil es gibt ja schon Internet.
Ja, es gibt ja auch nicht für jeden Internet. Das ist, wenn du jetzt so einen Schufa-Eintrag hast oder ein schlechtes sonstiges Scoring oder irgendwo gebrannt markt bist in dieser wunderschönen Katalysmuswelt, dann hast du nämlich tatsächlich...
Lass mich die Frage noch mal anders formulieren. Du würdest also sagen, wenn ich schon einen Internetanschluss habe, dann soll ich auch einen Freifunkrouter hinstellen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich möchte jetzt noch kurz vor den Nachrichten den Mic reinnehmen. Der hat nämlich selber schon mal Freifunk genutzt und will uns, glaube ich, seine Erfahrung mitteilen. Oder sehe ich das falsch, Mike?
Ja, so ähnlich. Genau. Ich wundere mich doch sehr, dass man hier in der multimedialen Mikropole Berlin sich mit solchen Themen auseinandersetzt. Denn ich habe so zwei, drei Jahre im tiefen Schwarzwald gewohnt, in so einem kleinen anderthalbtausend Seelendorf. Und es gab nichts, gar nichts sozusagen. Von daher war das die einzige Möglichkeit. Und jetzt nach ihnen, wo ich wieder ein Jahr lang hier in Berlin wohne, kriege ich langsam mit, aha, das hast du da genutzt. Das ist völlig geil. Ich habe irgendwann mal jemanden kennengelernt, der sagte, Mensch, da haben sich doch zwei, drei Leute im Dorf mal den Kopf drum gemacht. Wie macht man das eigentlich? Und das nächste größere Stadt, die älteste Stadt, war in Württemberg, fast so 12, 13 Kilometer entfernt. Und über sage und schreibe 56 Kilometer Richtungstrecke war dann diese Internetverbindung möglich.
Sportlich?
Ja, mit Bergen geht sowas, das ist großartig.
Ja, es war wirklich fantastisch. Aber bei schlechtem Wetter und vielen Blitzen und Stürmen, die nötige Pokersession war da oft unterbrochen.
Aber immerhin, es gab nichts. Wie habt ihr das finanziell geregelt?
Das war auch ein Thema, was mich mal interessieren würde. Freifunkmäßig habe ich jetzt immer so gehört, jeder schließt sich an. Da ist es irgendwie anders gelaufen. Also eine Firma hat sich da selbstständig gemacht und hat die Hardware angeboten. Und wir haben eine D-Link Modem gekauft, für 100 ungefähr, und mussten eine Antenne, die ungefähr 900 Euro wohl hätte kosten sollen, für ungefähr 20, 30 Euro, wenn ich mich nur noch mieten würde.
Für das ganze Dorf aber?
Nein, für einen Haushalt.
Okay, jeder musste einen Router kaufen und für 20 Euro pro Monat so ein Ding mieten?
Genau, es ist so eine kleine Antenne, die ist so groß wie eine Konfekt-Shuttle, kann man sagen. Bei mir war zum Beispiel dieser Fakt, dass ich den Wasserturm im Dorf nicht sehen konnte. Der Nachbar arbeitete ziemlich gut, also ging aus meinem Fenster raus, in sein Fenster rein und dann zum Wasserturm und dann auf die 54 Kilometer. Hat funktioniert. Ich hab's niemals gehört, dass es so was gibt. Der ACB-Funk hab ich damals auch gemacht, da waren noch die Packet-Leute alle da, wo es furchtbare Geräusche gab, aber es hat halt geklappt. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, es war schon irgendwo spektakulär. Allerdings war es teuer, muss ich echt sagen. Also ich hab dafür einen normalen DSL-Anschluss, so locker mal 80 Euro bezahlt im Monat.
Okay, das liegt aber an der Hand, dass sozusagen von der Firma organisiert wurde. Wenn das Ganze ein Privatprojekt gewesen wäre, wäre das natürlich anders.
Ja, in der Tat, auf jeden Fall. Deswegen wundert mich jetzt, dass es so, ja, frei zugänglich, sag ich mal, in Anführungsstrichen jetzt hier auch funktionieren sollte. Denn natürlich für uns damals die wesentlich bessere Variante gewesen, vor allem die günstigere Variante. Aber so hat man auch einen Techniker gehabt, der vorbeigekommen ist und den ganzen Krämpel alles installiert hat. Und es hat funktioniert.
Allerweise kombiniert man dann einfach beides, holt sich einmal so ein Ding und verteilt es dann einfach weiter.
So, das wäre natürlich, wenn man gewusst hätte, was es eigentlich ist.
Naja, beim nächsten Mal ein Schwarzfall ziehen, du bist auf jeden Fall schlauer. Aber wo wir jetzt gerade schon dabei sind, du bist jetzt wieder in Berlin, da hast du ja jetzt, und du hast jetzt die Sendung auch irgendwie gehört, wirst du dir jetzt auch einen Freifunkrouter ins Fenster stellen?
Also in der Tat, ja, was soll ich sagen, also von der Sache wollte ich gar kein Wissen, der das irgendwie brauchen würde. Jetzt gerade, bevor er mich reingenommen hat, kam ja eigentlich so die Möglichkeit, von wegen gut die Leute, die wegen Schufa oder Tempel da irgendwo nicht den Zugang haben, für die würde ich das natürlich sinnvoll finden und mich auch daran beteiligen, dann hätte ich gar kein Problem. Aber ansonsten wäre ich gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen, wer sowas hier hätte nötig oder brauchen würde, sage ich mal, weil eigentlich ist hier das Internet allgegenwärtig. Ich kann mich erinnern, wir waren im Sommer mal irgendwo mit einem Boot draußen gewesen, da nimmt man so ein kleines Netbook raus, hat UMTS, alles ist wunderbar. Also wer braucht das hier, sage ich mal.
Gut, aber so sagen, also irgendwie Netbook und UMTS, das haben ziemlich viele Leute, aber das ist schon auch ein gewisser finanzieller Aufwand. Du musst das Netbook gekauft haben, du musst ein Mobilfunkding ins haben, wo du wahrscheinlich entweder Multisim hast oder einen zweiten Anschluss und du musst diese Online-Cosmetale, das ist schon Luxus, möchte ich immer sagen.
Das ist auch schon mal eine Ecke schicker, wenn man irgendwie sein Notebook aufklappt und dann da Freifunk hat und nicht sich über diesen UMTS-Strohhalm retten muss, also die 5-Giga-Arbeit, die man da so hat oder weniger.
Also will sagen, es könnte schon Sinn machen.
Will sagen, finde ich eine sehr interessante Sache, weil ich mich mit befassen.
Alles klar, dann viel Spaß dabei. So, jetzt haben wir schon geklärt, wer Geschichte hat, wir haben die Technik im Kleinen, also quasi pro Mensch der Freifunk nutzen will, die Technik im Groß, nämlich wie versorge ich ein ganzes Boot, wollte ich keiner sagen, weil gerade auf dem See war ein ganzes Dorf mit...
Internet heißt das eben.
Ja, die Sendung ist nur zwei Stunden lang, aber trotzdem passiert es immer wieder, dass das Chaos zuschlägt. Ich habe für diesen Fall mal was vorbereitet. Hören Sie überhaupt noch zu?
Und das hört man.
Das muss auch mal gesagt werden. Wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde Chaos Radio. Jetzt machen wir erst mal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht es gleich weiter. Heute Chaos Radio mit mir, der ich hier Knöpfchen drücken und so ein bisschen rummoderieren darf und außerdem Nibla vom Chaos Computer Club. Tag nochmal und Alex von den Freifunkern. Es geht nämlich heute um Freifunk. Wir haben gerade, es gibt einen Chat zur Sendung im IRC und da hieß es gerade der MW hier, Chaos Computer Club und überhaupt Personalausweis neu müsste man da nicht mal. Und überhaupt, das gab es letztes Mal schon. Also wenn euch für das Für und Wider des Personalausweises interessiert, dann könnt ihr auf chaosradio.ccc.de gehen und dort den letzten Podcast vom letzten Chaos Radio runterladen.
Allerdings sei dazu gesagt, wer morgen noch nichts vorhat oder wem der alte Personalausweis wichtig ist und da keinen neuen elektronischen Personalausweis mit all seinen Problemen und potenziellen Unsicherheiten haben möchte, der sollte morgen schnurstracks ins Bürgeramt oder allgemein halt die Behörde gehen, wo man sich sowas abholen kann, ein Untermeldeamt und noch einen alten Personalausweis beantragen. Das geht nämlich nur noch morgen.
Und ich habe gehört, man soll, wenn man das machen will, tatsächlich ganz früh unterwegs sein, weil wohl viele Bürgeramte um elf schon zumachen wegen neuer Technik einrichten. Hätten wir das auch geklärt, hier aber Freifunk, Freifunk also ein, ach nö wir fragen Alex einfach wieder. Alex, was ist denn eigentlich Freifunk?
Freifunk ist ein Modelleisenbahnclub für Nerds, die keine Lust mehr haben, in Kellern Modelleisenbahnschienen aneinander zu machen und deshalb große Linkstrecken quer durch Berlin ziehen. Und das können die dann auf der Karte angucken, wie fett die Linien da sind.
Das Ganze wird nur gemacht, damit es auf der Karte geil fett aussieht. So, wir haben schon geklärt, wie man dazu gekommen ist, geschichtlich, wie man technisch dazu kommt. Also im Prinzip sendungsmäßig sind wir jetzt in der Situation, dass wir hier Freifunk am Start haben. Was kann ich denn jetzt damit machen?
Ja, unglaublich viel. Also technisch gesehen hast du ein... Hör ich mich krieg? Technisch gesehen hast du ein Intranet. Das heißt, du hast da ein Netzwerk, damit kommst du einmal ins Internet und du kannst mit anderen Teilnehmern dieses Netzwerks kommunizieren. Kommunikation kann ganz viel sein. Es kann sein, dass du jetzt im Hausprojekt wohnst und da ist eine Punkband und die hat einen Auftritt und dann kannst du das ins Freifunknetz streamen. Oder, das wurde glaube ich sogar schon gemacht, oder da gibt es einen Kirchturm und da gibt es ein Falkennest mit einem Turmfalken und dann kannst du da eine Webcam aufhängen und kannst diesem Falken beim Brüten zuhören. Das machen zum Beispiel die Kiezfunker. Die haben da halt einen Rechner hingestellt und eine Kamera hingemacht und das ist sowieso, die Technik muss funktionieren, weil wenn der Falk gebrütet, dann kann man da keine Antennen schrauben, aber dafür kann man dem Falken zusehen. Und haben die Falkencam, das geht einmal innerhalb des Freifunknetzes und das geht natürlich auch im Internet, weil das wird auch noch hochgeladen. Aber ist natürlich nicht so schick. Und jetzt weiß ich, in NRW sind ein paar Leute, die diese Idee, die ich auch schon lange propagiert habe, mal machen wollen, die wollen nämlich eine Linkstrecke zwischen der Kirche und dem Altenheim machen, um die Sonntagspredigt zu streamen. Auch mal eine Lösung. Dann haben wir natürlich irgendwie alle unsere kleinen FTP-Server, die wir zu Hause stehen haben. Kennt man ja, man guckt mal einen Film und man hat den Film auf der Platte, weil das ist die legale Kopie, die man sich da auf der Platte aufbewahrt. Und die möchte man natürlich im Freundeskreis tauschen. Die sogenannte Privatkopie im Freundeskreis. Und das kann man natürlich auch ganz gut über das Freifunknetz machen. Und wenn man sich natürlich die Mühe macht, diese schicke Outdoor-Hardware, von der wir eben gesprochen hatten, nicht über acht Kilometer, sondern nur über 300 Meter Funken zu lassen, dann kann man da ohne Probleme 50 bis 70 MBit und mehr durchkriegen. Und das ist ganz schön satt. Damit kann man nämlich den Film direkt aus der Nachbarschaft streamen.
Aber das heißt, man kann also innerhalb dieses Netzwerks relativ viel machen. Aber wie ist es denn jetzt mit dem Internet-TM? Also habe ich da einfach einen richtigen vollwertigen Internetanschluss, wo ich alles machen kann? Oder muss ich da schon Einschränkungen hinnehmen?
Ja, also ein bisschen ausholen. Bei deinem DSL-Provider gilt das Prinzip, you get what you pay for. Du kannst ja da den kleinen Anschluss holen. Da hast du zwei Mbit, kriegst ein bisschen Internet. Oder du holst dir VDSL und hast da irgendwie richtig viel Internet. Und bei Freifunk funktioniert das generell ganz ähnlich. Nur, dass du halt, dass die Währungseinheit, die du investierst, ist halt nicht eine monatliche Zahlung. Und das versackt dann irgendwo bei deinem Provider. Und der kauft sich davon Porsche. Sondern die Frage ist, wie viel Zeit und Hardware investierst du? Also wenn du dir deinen Router ins Fenster stellst, dann kriegst du ein bisschen Internet. Und vielleicht auch mal eine Unterbrechung. Und wenn du Glück hast, gibst YouTube in Flüssig. Und wenn du Pech hast, musst du halt mal auf Play drücken und auf Pause drücken und ne 5 Minuten warten. Und kannst es dann abspielen. Wenn du natürlich investierst und was ausgibst, ja, da waren wir, you get what you pay for, und sagst okay, ich kauf mir von Ubiquiti eine Nano Station, das ist halt so ein Plastorouter in Wettefest, und schraub mir den aufs Dach und red mit der Gegenstelle und der dreht seine Antenne noch ein bisschen, dann kriegst du plötzlich viel schnelleres Internet. Und das Ganze läuft viel flüssiger. Wenn du natürlich jetzt sagst, okay, guck mal hier lieber Nachbar, willst du deinen DSL-Anschluss nicht noch ein bisschen upgraden und ich geb dir noch mal einen 5er im Monat oder einen 10er im Monat dazu, das ist immer noch billiger als mir meinen eigenen zu holen, dann wird dein Internet noch schneller. Das heißt, die Frage ist eigentlich, wie sehr bringst du dich ein? Wenn du nur konsumierst und einfach nur deinen Router ins Fenster stellst, dann machst du das Netz ein bisschen besser und kriegst ein bisschen Netz. Wenn du die ultra geile Dachinstallation baust mit einem Schaltkasten und sieben Antennen in alle Richtungen der Welt und ein fetter Knoten bist, dann hast du natürlich eine bessere Anbindung an das restliche Netz. Was auch dort gilt, du entscheidest darüber, wie gut das Netz ist in Form von Engagement. Und manchmal hast du halt das Glück, dass du neben jemandem wohnst, der dieses Engagement treibt, wie zum Beispiel einen Nachbar, dann kriegst du auch so schnelles Netz.
Das heißt also, um das mal festzuhalten, es ist nicht so, wie jetzt vielleicht die, wie heißen die, die Parasiten der Gesellschaft, die jetzt denken, ha ha, kostenloses Internet für mich, das funktioniert nicht, sondern es ist schon ein Ding, das auch davon lebt, das auch wirklich jeder mitmacht. Und im Zweifelsfall, wenn man es sich leisten kann, auch sozusagen einen eigenen Internetanschluss haben und den dann auch damit reinwerfen. Wie ist es denn rechtlich gesehen? Das ist ja eine Frage, die schon aufgetaucht ist. Und wie gesagt, es gibt eine ganze Sendung, aber nur noch mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst. Ich habe jetzt einen Internetanschluss, mache bei diesem Freifunk mit. Irgendjemand macht darüber Unsinn, kann ich dann belangt werden?
Grundsätzlich ist das in dem Prozess der Klärung. Wir hatten dieses BGH-Urteil. Das BGH hat gesagt, also du kannst deinen Internetanschluss, also es hat ja noch von einem Accesspoint gesprochen, nicht einfach so betreiben. Du musst da Sicherungsmaßnahmen betreiben. Und die müssen auf dem Stand der Technik sein. Wenn du dein Gerät einrichtest, dann bist du nicht dazu verpflichtet, diese Sicherungsmaßnahmen fortlaufend zu verbessern. Das heißt, das, was du vor 5 Jahren eingestellt hast, wenn das damals Stand der Technik war, dann ist das in Ordnung. Der BGH hat da natürlich diese ganze WPA, WPA2-Nummer irgendwie gemeint. Das ist aber halt genau das, was wir nicht machen, nämlich Gartenzäune bauen. Wir wollen ja irgendwie eine große gemeinsame Wiese, auf der wir irgendwie miteinander und nicht viele kleine Zäune und jeder macht sein eigenes Ding. Aber auch schon vor dem BGH-Urteil und auch schon vor diesem Prozess haben wir uns natürlich überlegt, so Filesharing, BitTorrent, E-Dunkey und so weiter. Das kann man zwar auch für legale Inhalte benutzen, aber es gibt ja auch tatsächlich Leute, oder es gab Leute, die haben sich gedacht, hach, ich hab zwar DSL, aber wenn ich jetzt Filesharing mach, benutze ich doch das Freifunk, dann bin ich dafür nicht haftbar. Es ist noch asozialer, als irgendwie ohne DSL irgendwie Freifunk für Filesharing zu benutzen, ist sein eigenen DSL-Anschluss auszusparen, um zu hoffen, dass jemand anders dafür haftet. Daraufhin haben wir darum verschiedene Leute gesagt, ja so geht das aber nicht, und haben entsprechende Technik entwickelt. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt einen Internetanschluss hast und möchtest den zur Verfügung stellen, dann, der Lutz hat ja schon mal gefragt, kannst du auf der einen Seite schon mal einstellen, wie viel du davon zur Verfügung stellst? Und dann gibt es verschiedene Sorten von Peer-to-Peer-Blockern. Das heißt, es gibt da eine Software, und die guckt sich diese Pakete an, und die sagt dann ja, hm, guck mal hier, idanki, nicht so gut, das drossel ich jetzt mal auf ein Kilobit oder so. Und dann läuft das nicht. Und eine andere Software, das wird bei uns das Zappscript genannt, das zappt deinen Internetanschluss einfach und leitet dich auf eine Seite um, und da steht dann, du, du, du, das war wohl eine scheiß Idee, die du erhattest, wenn du hier auf OK klickst, hast du jetzt erstmal wieder eine Stunde Internet, aber schick mal eine Mail irgendwie und lass uns mal miteinander reden. Das ist das Zappscript, das hat auch der Fels Sven Ola gebaut. Und wir haben die Erfahrung gemacht, gerade in der Nähe von Jugendeinrichtungen, dass dieses Zappscript ein paar mal zuschlägt und dann alle gelernt haben, dass wenn sie irgendwie Mist machen, das Zappscript irgendwie ihnen auf die Finger klopft. Und haben halt in der Anfangsphase des Einsatzes noch ein paar Alarme gehabt, aber das ist dann auch ganz schnell zurückgegangen, weil dann auch jeder noch mal drüber reflektiert. Was mache ich hier eigentlich? Ich könnte irgendwie tatsächlich, vielleicht kriegt der andere ja Ärger und eigentlich will ich das ja gar nicht. Und eigentlich habe ich darüber gar nicht nachgedacht. Jetzt habe ich drüber nachgedacht und jetzt lasse ich das. Und wenn ich nicht drüber nachdenke, dann kriege ich halt weiter auf die Finger geklopft.
Das ist wie bei so verletzten Computern immer. Man muss sich halt vor Augen führen, dass am anderen Ende des Geräts nicht nur irgendwas sitzt, was irgendwie Textbuchstaben ausspuckt, sondern ein Mensch.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass das zwar ein lobuswerter Ansatz ist, aber dass man ja davon ausgehen muss, dass da trotzdem irgendwie ein paar Spacken draußen sind. Ist denn schon mal ein Freifunker verurteilt worden?
Verurteilt nicht. Es wird immer eingestellt. Weil die haben, glaube ich, auch gar keine Lust, das durchzufechten. Und dann kommt da ein Urteil raus, was ihnen nicht passt. Weil wenn du dem Richter sagst, guck mal hier, wir haben hier zwei ganz legitime Interessen. Das eine ist irgendwie das Interesse der Content-Mafia an ihrem geistigen Eigentum und das zu verwerten und das ist nach unserer Rechtslage legitim. Deshalb bezeichne ich das hier jetzt auch als legitim, auch wenn man darüber jetzt anderer Meinung sein kann. Auf der anderen Seite eine Gruppe von Menschen, die die digitale Spaltung überwinden will, die freien Zugang zu Wissen und Bildung für alle möchte und das realisiert, indem sie freie Informationsinfrastruktur betreibt. Und wenn die Content-Mafia jetzt 100 Prozent Recht kriegt, dann kann dieses Netz nicht mehr betrieben werden. Wenn dieses Netz vollständig frei und offen ist, dann können die Interessen der Content-Mafia nicht mehr geschützt werden. Das heißt, wir haben ja eine Rechtsgüterabwägung. Und am Ende dieser Abwägung steht mit ziemlicher Sicherheit, wie auch schon beim letzten BGH-Prozess, dass Maßnahmen zu ergreifen sind. Und genau das tun wir. Wir haben nämlich zwei Elemente. Das eine ist das Acceptklicken. Das ist nämlich Nutzungsbedingungen. Und diese wirst also tatsächlich darüber belehrt und du musst diesen Nutzungsbedingungen zustimmen. Und wenn du das gemacht hast, dann kannst du erst ins Netz. Und wenn du gegen die Nutzungsbedingungen verstößt, dann kann der Ablinkbetreiber erst mal nichts dafür. Und wir haben diese Peer-to-Peer-Blocker und dieses Zappscript, welche sehr wirksame technische Maßnahmen zu Verhinderung sind. Sie können es nicht zu 100 Prozent verhindern. Das heißt, vielleicht kannst du noch 50 Kilobyte von diesem Pfeil runterladen, bis du es aufgibst. Das heißt, du kannst immer noch in den Fischnetzen der Abmahnanwälte landen. Aber man kann nachweisen, dass das ein kleines Rinsel war, was dann...
Und man lässt sich selber auch sagen, was dagegen unternommen ist.
Genau, man hat eine Maßnahme ergriffen nach dem aktuellen Stand der Technik. Und hat es nicht einfach fahrlässig in Kauf genommen. Es gibt die Aktion Freifunk statt Angst. Die findet man auf dem Internet. Und da sind jede Menge Aktivisten und Juristen und so weiter, die sich da zusammengetan haben, um solche Fälle zu bearbeiten. Und es ist immer eine gute Sache, auch an die Freifunk statt Angst Geschichte zu spenden, um diese Sache zu unterstützen. Aber dort nimmt man sich dann solcher Fälle an. Und dann gibt es normalerweise die modifizierte Unterlassungserklärung. Und dann ist die Content Mafia auch ganz schnell wieder ruhig, weil sie festgestellt hat, die wären sicher. Nee, da kann man ja gar kein Geld verdienen. Da gibt es ja nur scheiß Presse. Und wir kriegen noch mehr aus dem Maul und lassen mal lieber. Also Verurteilung in dem Sinne gar nicht, sondern es wird eingestellt.
Eine spannende Sache, die mir gerade aufgefallen ist. Es gibt ja derzeit oder es gab sozusagen vor einiger Zeit, und es ist noch nicht ganz vorbei, die Diskussion um Netzneutralität, wo es ja genau darum geht, dass eigentlich sozusagen dieses wir gucken uns andere Leute Daten an, nicht gewollt ist. Da hast du gerade erzählt, dass genau das aber gemacht wird in den Routern, dass man nämlich die Daten anguckt und dann so guckt, wo die herkommen. Gibt es da so kleine Glaubenskriege? Also weil so Freifunker und sind ja auch eher in dieser Richtung, so freies Netz und so was unterwegs. Aber da scheint sich das ein bisschen zu widersprechen.
Man muss da zwei Dinge unterscheiden. Das eine ist der freie Transit im Freifunknetz. Da gilt das sogenannte Pico Peering Agreement. Das wurde damals bei dieser Consumnet in London Geschichte vor Ewigkeiten entwickelt. Das besagt, ich kann das natürlich jetzt nicht runterbeten, aber das besagt im wesentlichen Verkehr von deinen Nachbarn, sollst du frei durchleiten, du sollst dafür auch kein Geld nehmen und so weiter und so fort. Es sagt aber auch, du kannst zusätzliche Dienste anbieten, du darfst dafür auch Geld nehmen und diese Dienste kannst du unter eigenen Nutzungsbedingungen anbieten. Internet Uplink ist ein solcher Dienst. Das heißt, wir sagen klar, der Treffig im Netz muss, also innerhalb des Freifunknetzes muss vollständig diskriminierungsfrei sein. Wir würden das auch sehr, sehr, sehr gerne über die DSL Uplinks machen. Und wir machen das auch dort, wo wir es können. Das heißt, es gibt gewisse Uplinks, wo wir andere Schutzschirme gegen die Bösen haben. Da filtern wir nicht, aber wir haben leider keine Wahl. Es wird bestimmt auch wieder Thema werden in den nächsten Jahren, wie man das verbessern kann. Aber da muss man tatsächlich an der Gesetzeslage arbeiten. Da gibt es Urteile, da gibt es Gesetze, da gibt es unterschiedliche Auffassungen auch. Und ich denke, das sind politische Prozesse. Und solange sind wir leider dazu gezwungen.
Also dass ihr sozusagen gegen die ideale Netzneutralität, wenn ich das mal verstoße, ist im Prinzip eine pragmatische Lösung, um keinen Ärger zu kriegen. Aber ihr hättet lieber, dass es nicht so ist.
Selbstverständlich.
So, ich wage es kaum zu glauben, aber zwölf Minuten vor Mitternacht scheint mir, wir haben jetzt einen ziemlich guten Abriss gehabt über das, was Freifunk ist und was es kann. Was fehlt noch?
Ja, Freifunk.
Du würdest doch etwa sagen, dass wir sozusagen zwei Stunden, dass zwei Stunden genug sind für ein so umfangreiches und komplexes Thema.
Nein, wir haben es jetzt kurz angerissen. Was ganz interessant ist, ist, dass Freifunk tatsächlich Entwicklungsarbeit in Bereichen geleistet hat und da bessere Arbeit geleistet hat als Forschung und Technik und inzwischen die Forschung sich das ziemlich genau anguckt, was wir da machen.
Inwiefern?
Naja, es muss man sagen, dass diese Mesh-Netze und die waren eine Zeit lang für die Wissenschaftler ganz interessant und die haben dann ganz viele Papers geschrieben und Standards gemacht und wir haben die dann immer ausgelacht. Wie gesagt, ist ja schön, dass du da was simuliert hast, aber wir haben hier irgendwie 600 Knoten über Berlin und 450 Knoten über Leipzig.
Angeber.
Klappt alles nicht so, wie du das vorstellst und inzwischen bringen wir uns in die Standardisierungsprozesse mit ein, in die IETF, die Internet Engineering Task Force und bauen an den neuen Internetstandards mit, wo dann wieder ein paar Wissenschaftler sagen, ja, aber theoretisch sieht das so ganz gut aus und dann kommt so ein Programmierer und sagt, komm mal mit auf den Kirchturm hier. Genau. Wir haben hier 600 Knoten und guck dir mal den Kirchturm an und guck dir mal diese Topologie an und guck dir diese Interferenzen an und dann sagt er, ja, das sieht aber alles ganz anders aus als in meiner Simulation und das wiederum hat dazu geführt, dass sie jetzt überall auf der Welt anfangen, quasi Freifunknetze für Forschungszwecke zu bauen. Das fing an am MIT natürlich, die sind immer fünf Jahre vor allen, anders, aber das ist ja auch das MIT. Und die TU Berlin baut ein Testbett, die HU baut ein Testbett, die Beuth Hochschule hat eine Dachinstallation.
Aber machen die da bei euch mit oder bauen jetzt ihre eigenen Kram, der ja nicht kompatibel ist?
Unterschiedlich. Also die TU-Installation könnte man, glaube ich, mit drei Knopf drücken in ein Freifunknetz umwandeln, die kann aber grundsätzlich alles sprechen. Die HU-Leute machen Berlin Roof Net, das ist was, das kann man undocken. Insofern ist es kompatibel, aber es ist eine eigene Technologie und sowohl Fraunhofer als auch Beuth Hochschule betreiben Dachstandorte, die in das Freifunknetzwerk integriert sind. Und bei Fraunhofer sitzt dann auch wieder jemand, der sich damit beschäftigt, wie man diese Netze vielleicht praxisnah simulieren kann und betreibt da auch wieder Forschungsarbeit.
Und damit wir wieder beim Chaos, ja.
Wir sagen, um das nochmal abzuschließen und vor allen Dingen weiterzuführen für alle Leute, die jetzt diese zwei Stunden sich angetan haben und denken, hey, Freifunk, das ist cool, da will ich mitmachen. freifunk.net ist schon gefallen, das ist die Webseite, wo ihr unterwegs seid, wo man sich auch ziemlich viel anlesen kann. Wo kann man euch in Berlin treffen?
Also es gibt in Berlin, es gibt die SeaBase, die Raumstation unter Berlin. Ich glaube, die wurde hier schon häufiger erwähnt. Da treffen sich die Freifunker am Mittwoch. Dann gibt es am Donnerstag im Herbert das Freifunk Berlin Nordost Treffen. Es gibt am Montag im Platzhaus in Pregnant Hill den Kiezfunkertreff. Es gibt, glaube ich, noch ein Treff in Kreuzberg. Der Friedrichshainer ist ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Es gibt eine aktive Freifunk-Community im Sublab in Leipzig. Es gibt im Maschinenraum in Weimar eine aktive Community. Es gibt eigentlich in jeder größeren deutschen Stadt Freifunk-Communities. Das wird normalerweise auch unter freifunk.net irgendwo verlinkt. Es gibt das Wiki, das ist wiki.freifunk.net. Da gibt es noch unglaublich viel mehr Informationen, vollständig unaufbereitet und diskordisch im Chaos. Sehr zu empfehlen, wenn man sich mit Antennen bauen und Routergehäuse bauen beschäftigen will, ist auch wiki.leipzig.freifunk.net. Man merkt, Freifunk ist dezentral. Freifunk ist organisch. Freifunk lebt. Menschen machen etwas und dann ist das Freifunk. Es gibt keine Freifunkbehörde. Es gibt auch keine zentrale Freifunkautorität. Es ist einfach dezentrales Chaos.
Aber trotzdem vielleicht nochmal für die Brandenburger, die jetzt denken, mein Dorf, wir haben einen Kirchturm, aber sonst noch kein Internet. Irgendjemand, an dem man sich am besten, also jemand, der sie vielleicht als besonders geeignet, als Ansprechpartner herausgestellt hat?
Also es ist hilfreich, sich auf der Freifunknet Mailingliste auf der WLAN-Werten zu melden und zu fragen, ob jemand in der Nähe wohnt. Die Berliner Mailingliste hilft auch. Wenn man die Freifunk Potsdam Leute kann man erreichen. Man kann auch einfach mal in der C-Base aufschlagen, sich vorher anmelden über die Liste und dann persönliche Kontakte herstellen. Normalerweise bildet sich dann ganz schnell, es kommt ja häufiger vor, dass Leute aus Gemeinden kommen und sagen, wir wollen das jetzt auch machen, dann bildet sich ziemlich schnell ein Kreis von unterschiedlichen Leuten aus den unterschiedlichen Fachbereichen und da wird Networking gemacht, da werden Kontakte geknüpft und dann kriegen die die nötige Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe, die Dokumentation, die Information und wo kriegt man die Technik und welche Fehler sollte man vermeiden und also das klappt eigentlich auch relativ gut. Mailing-Liste anmelden, sagen hey Leute, irgendwie gibt's mal einen Kontakt bei mir in der Gegend und dann wird der Kontakt meist recht schnell hergestellt.
Wo geht Freifunk hin? Also irgendwie, das hört sich ja alles ganz grov an. Ihr habt irgendwie so eine funktionierende Community am Start. Technisch ist es mittlerweile so weit, dass man es auch jemanden zumuten kann, der nicht mit einem Lötkolben umgeht. Gibt es da jetzt noch Weiterentwicklung? Oder irgendwo wo du sagst, das ist ein Meilenstein in der Zukunft, der noch bevorsteht uns?
Also natürlich mehr mehr, mehr Brandbreite, mehr Nodes. Aber was halt auch so Themen sind, ist Durchsuchbarkeit und Inhalte im Netz. Da ist schon angefangen, meine ganzen E-Books liegen im Netz. Das sind natürlich alles nur legale Scans von Büchern, die ich besitze. Und wie finde ich die Inhalte von den anderen? Wie publiziere ich Inhalte? Also was ich zum Beispiel gerne hätte, wäre so eine kleine Box mit Mikrofon dran und wo man noch einen Schalter umlegt und dann streamt das Ding, damit man einfach mal ganz einfach Konzerte und Predigten ins Netz streamen kann. Also viel mehr noch was passiert, weil wir haben halt wie gesagt die Content Mafia und die Abmahn-Anwälte und es gibt viele Dinge, die man viel besser in der Nachbarschaft machen kann. Also die interne Kommunikation. Technisch haben wir 802.11n mit Antennagrids und Beamforming und dann gibt es wiederum Mittel und Methoden, die erforscht werden, wie man die zentrale Synchronisation in verteilten Systemen erreichen kann, um dann halt den geeigneten Platz im Raum-Zeit-Continuum für sein Datenpaket zu finden, ohne dass dieses mit anderen kollidiert. Das ist alles irgendwie noch Rocket Science, aber wir partizipieren in der Firmenentwicklung, in der WLAN-Treiberentwicklung. Das heißt, inzwischen fressen wir nicht nur was hinten überfällt, sondern wir gestalten mit. Ich glaube, das wird in Zukunft noch viel mehr werden. Nämlich einfach neue Technologien mitgestalten und diese umzusetzen und auch irgendwie auf die Dächer zu bringen.
Also falls ihr jetzt einer von den wirklichen Hackern seid und gerade gesagt habt, oh Gott, Freifunk, da kann man sich noch Plastikkisten hinstellen, wo schon alles fertig ist, weit gefehlt. Ihr könnt auch richtig damit rumbasteln und sagen, an der Grenze zum Neuen forschen. Vielen Dank Alex von den Freifunkern.
Jetzt noch eine letzte Nachricht. Das wichtigste vergessen. IPv6 natürlich. Das neue Internet der nächsten Generation, unsere neuen Firmen, sind alle IPv6-fähig. Wir haben auch noch intelligente Mechanismen entwickelt, um das Alte mit dem Neuen migrationsmäßig zu machen. Und das ist eigentlich der Bereich, wo ganz, ganz viel passiert, weil unsere IP-Adressen werden noch ungefähr 240 Tage halten und dann gibt es keine neuen IPv4-Adressen mehr. Und spätestens dann muss das funktionieren. Da arbeiten auch wieder ganz viele Leute und da sind auch noch ganz viele ungelöste Probleme, wo es durchaus Fame gibt, im Form von Papers zu schreiben, RFCs zu schreiben und Referenzimplementationen zu machen.
Alles klar. freifunk.net ist die Adresse, wo ihr auch das nachschlagen könnt. Jetzt aber wirklich vielen Dank, Alex, fürs Vorbeikommen und das Erklären, was Freifunk eigentlich ist. Vielen Dank auch Nibbler vom CCC, der den Alex hierher geschleppt hat und Unterstützung gegeben hat. Viel Spaß euch. Ihr könnt euch, wenn ihr das alles noch einmal hören wollt, als Podcast runterladen, dürfte in ungefähr einer Stunde online sein. Was gibt es noch zu sagen? chaosradio.ccc.de, dort gibt es das, oder fritz.de. Hier kommt jetzt der Night Flight mit Florian Heiler. Wenn ihr wollt, hören wir uns im nächsten Monat wieder. Und Nibbler hat noch die Famous Last Words.
Nicht vergessen, morgen ist der letzte Tag für den alten Personalausweis.
Bis 11 Uhr, dann sollen angeblich die Bürgerämter zumachen. Ich sage noch, macht immer schon eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen und damit raus.